we're gonna have a lot of fun and uh
again hikaru
versus fedo save these guys have played
so much on chess.com i don't have the
stats in front of me i'm sure the team
will
their lifetime record obviously favors
nakamura but as you said
there's even been recent times where
they throw down in casual chess
and fedo saif has that ability to get
the better of hikara we've seen it
happen right we also know that
like artemyev we say this about the
motherland a lot right robert sometimes
there's just super gm's just hanging
around in russia right
guys like fedor sam and artemyev aren't
as as big a household names as as
grishak or
uh nepamyashi but they're they're very
good and very capable
oh for sure i mean the russian super
finals coming up i heard you
wish artemy of well there you have peter
svidler who's won that eight times and
because of the likes of svidler
grifsherk as you just mentioned
karjakin etc these other players who are
super strong
don't get the attention that they would
if they were from a country less
populated by chess superstars
right yeah and uh it's the the culture
there
you know the uh the amount of uh chess
that people are exposed to at a young
age
uh we we talked about the fact that fedo
said actually grew up in the same town
as a niche geary uh last time vladimir
here was on camera anishgiri was my
co-commentator as
uh he took on albireza farouza so
there's just a lot a lot of chess stars
from a lot of different places around
russia
and then we have the man himself the
american the number one
chess streamer in the world sporting his
hoodie by the way sportingthechest.com
hoodie i got you one of those right
robert
yeah you did uh i just i don't wear it
but i i have it somewhere i know but i
was about i thought you were gonna do
the thing we're like no danny you didn't
which proves you love a car or more and
you're
i thought we were gonna have the whole
fight but we didn't have to do that it
was so cool are you trying to start
fights just to prove how
you know well we get along like that's
what you're doing just so we can you
know how i you know how much i love
fighting because of the makeup chess
you and i have the best makeup chest in
the business buddy
um all right are we about to cut cut
this chess you will tension with a knife
i'm ready
i don't know who else is ready i mean i
think a car in federer look at federer
by the way yeah he's he's looking ready
to go
i mean he he's got like that that boxer
hoodie on right and he's got
he's got that white and red combo i mean
the guy is just
he's in for a battle and he's got a car
nakamura ahead
that is as tough as it gets him
alongside magnus carlson
you're playing them for hours you're
going to be in for it but what do you
think danny
so fedo say of underdog he knows that we
know that
what does he need to do to give himself
the best chance in the first few games
i i kind of feel like he needs to strike
early you know hammer and i talked a lot
about the momentum the underdog needs
in terms of getting two wins in a row
that feels like the magical number which
by the way
artemia was not able to do until the
final minutes of bullet right so it did
prove right that
the thing about the top seed is when
they lose they very rarely lose again
and i think if the upset is gonna happen
you have to find a way whether it's in
the five minute or the three minute
portion
to put their back against the wall
because yeah they're good but they also
don't have to play with those tilt
emotions
as often as others so if you can put
hikaru in that spot
will he be able to recover from what
could be consecutive losses so i'll say
robert the answer to the question is no
matter where it happens at some point
fedo say
needs to win two games in a row to have
a chance here
and this is going to be a funny
statement before we get into the chess
specifics
but obviously hikar nakamura has the
most wins on the server he plays so much
but he also has a large number of losses
just because of the
quantity of games he has played he wins
way more often but he does have
experience losing
and that may not sound important but as
you're saying fedozer will need to win a
couple in a row
and when carl plays there are times
where some other very strong grandmaster
gets a couple hikara calms himself down
and then ends up winning the match
anyway so
right now out of the gates we have the
semi-solve a
solid structure for black look at this
pawn triangle
heading towards the center it means that
it's going to be a hard central position
to crack
even though that light square bishop on
c8 dany reminds us of the french
we hate it when we're reminded of the
french the opening not the people
uh but yeah no the uh the bishop there
at some point the pawn chain will break
we just talked a lot about this in the
carlson versus artemiv match because the
semi-slot was featured regularly
never this exact variation though i will
note for the record uh but here goes
hicaro
speeding up a little bit after a think
before playing bishop g5
um and uh we have a semi-slav
didn't quite reach a baud vinnick
variation but that's because white
sacrifices the bishop pair to have the
big center
what what's going on in this structure
as black tries to prepare for the
liberating breakthroughs
what's white doing to be ready for that
yeah white has a choice you can play
knight e4 or you could have played 94 to
actually get the
bishop off the board the d6 bishop but
he likes his knight on c3 he wants to
push his pawns
in the center because the best way to
challenge pieces are with pawns
and if you do play e4 the one thing you
always have to be ready for is e5
or c5 black will try to break in return
and more broadly speaking the d4 square
is less protected so even if black
doesn't break with the pawn
at some point d4 could be a potential
issue yeah well hikaru's thinking now
and
actually chooses queen d3 instead of e4
and a quick castles from the big fish
rook d1 preparing to meet e5 and c5 the
tactical way perhaps
um and so black being down in
development
and white preparing the center the
structure is
still very solid for black but you have
to be careful because if too much prep
is done
and you still haven't changed the
formation now the space can get real
right and it can be hard to
react so what is what is fedocide going
to be thinking about here
a common idea is to actually play for b5
at some point
and then uh you advance your queen side
pause this is a double-edged sword
because playing
b5 gives black critical space on the
queen
side and it also gives the bishop access
on a new diagonal he does go for b6
a calmer approach i think that you know
going forward depending on the match
situation the difference between b6 and
b5
will be noticeable it will vladimir play
something a little more aggressive now
he says it's game one
i don't need to take these big
structural risks i'm gonna play b6
i'm going to play bishop b7 i'm going to
prepare my pawn break with c5 or e5
when the time is 100 correct yeah and
that's what we're going to go for but
while we have the analysis board i'll
just say again the b5 while it is more
structurally committal
it's also the very common idea which is
why robert said we'll probably see it
black can follow with a6 and c5 is still
eventually coming with the diagonal so
really just an interesting stylistic
choice but i'll say
showing hey it's early in the match let
me take a little more flexible
of an approach here where i'm preparing
still both of these moves
uh before i've committed anything so uh
we see uh
both guys pretty focused hikara in a
position he's now known very well for
streaming uh regularly every day and
then vladimir putin will say we've
gotten to know that bookshelf behind him
despite the hoodie being new
yeah he yeah he's a familiar face these
days
and he is trying to combat the uh
aggressive approach now by hikar putting
the bishop to a6
trying to take advantage of the
compromised
light squares on the queen side you have
a bishop there for now but i'm getting
rid of
what doesn't look like a great piece
just to take advantage of the remaining
squares
and by the way danny i'm looking at it
fedo sayo's internet connection
not very good continuing to go to one
bar
and actually that's probably why he's
spending so much time less so about the
actual chest position it seems like uh
he's struggling with that connection
well we actually see him uh
he's actually he's he's frozen
completely elsa he needs to let it go
right reset and reboot the router
um you know what they say about that
spotty wi-fi right sometimes the wi-fi
router is capable of more than your
connection and
you know never mind whole thing but no
but jokes aside that's actually really
too bad remember it is part of the rules
part of the game the players are
responsible for a great connection we
will see what happens
we have fedor say of on the line or not
yeah and uh hickar waiting here i i
wonder if he
realizes he could see the bar of
connection on top of the
screen but you know sometimes the
players like to look at the zoom calls
just as if they're playing over the
board yeah i wonder if he is
i bet he does i bet he does um in fact
there we go we see
the zoom call drop and while we wait for
the reconnection why don't we bring back
the bracket because i want to talk about
one thing real quick before the game
starts which is that this
is the last seat that has not been
filled yet so for those who somehow
maybe missed the earlier
part of today's double header magnus
carlson did move on
so there is only one spot remaining
before we have a full semi-final bracket
remember the semi-finals and finals will
take place december 11th 12th and 13th
mark your calendar next week and going
to be a busy one and we're back
the the chess is back we don't know the
players on camera yet but we'll keep the
chess going rook b8 was played by the
way followed by an exchange robert as
you said this eliminates the defense of
the c6 pawn
how cecaro gonna take advantage of that
he has his options here i'm wondering
if he will ever play the move e3 to e4
it doesn't need to instead use it for
the knight and that's something that he
has
been keeping away from this pawn push so
that he can keep the square open for
night that hits the bishop on d6
but also opens the c file the rook on c1
staring down the pawn on c6
the a6 square in addition to c6 is
white's for the taking
so fedoceav not only has internet
connection issues he has
control issues with all these squares on
the queen side and the bishop
on d6 is particularly useless for the
time being that's a dark square piece
there are no dark squares that you're
really wanting to take advantage of
and in fact it's a bit superfluous with
that queen sitting there on e7 you're
not you're stepping on each other's toes
you're not actually controlling too much
so the knight on e4 is much better than
this bishop on d6 right now
yeah i will say we often talk about a
centralized knight
being able to keep pace with a bishop
that's better on the long diagonals and
open board
i will say i like the way federal safe
is coordinated to to deal with the
weakness
and don't forget that in these
structures even though you've had less
space for a really long time and maybe
not
ideal pieces as we were just
highlighting if the pieces get traded
and you eventually kind of simplify
the long-term advantages of that carroll
slob structure is it's very solid
there's there's no other real weaknesses
long-term besides the c6 pawn
um we'll see what a car can do now we're
glad to see fedo say of having
fixed his internet woes whatever they
were back to a four bar connection on
chess.com and a
and a beautiful zoom camera and a
beautiful subscription right there from
shine90 thank you so much for the
support everybody
it's been a great day and i mean
for you it's been a long day already for
me i i was watching you and hammer
hammer did a great job by the way you
always do a great job i don't need to
compliment you but hammer was
excellent uh very sharp and uh youtube
made a great team
uh but danny i gotta say this connection
for fedor say it is concerning me
he needs to be at his absolute best to
put up a fight with takara nakamura yeah
his internet connection not doing him
any favors right now it's kind of it's
time to go tell junior to stop
downloading netflix right hey you've
seen nemo seven times
no more watching nemo or streaming on
netflix when dad's playing in the scc
oh gosh one bar and uh you know
unfortunately for him his position is
okay and from his
chess specific point of view he gets in
c5 and
if you accomplish that you were just
saying danny black's position is very
stable you're getting rid of your
weakness
there were two rooks on a semi-open file
aiming towards that pawn
now it's on a square protected by all
these other pieces we're trying to trade
it off
and then liquidate into an equal ending
so maybe i was
overly harsh about the position for
black i tend to not like these more
passive structures
better say perfectly fine over the board
as for the internet connection dave that
he's got to fix that for sure he does
he's back to one bar though it's
bouncing all around this is why i said
it
it actually you know jokes aside and as
personal as that sounded uh
i do fight my daughters for the netflix
man with on a regular basis
uh there may be something going on
seriously at home because this
we know federal sam's internet is stable
i did a whole match with him versus
ferugia
never had that problem he plays on
chess.com in the dozens of games daily
so
whatever's going on jokes aside he does
need to fix his his wifi
and this actually might be a very
serious thing because taking on f6
with the queen or the the pawn that's
not as
easy of a decision as many people would
think oh why would i double my pawns
with g takes f6
but it by taking with the queen on f6
and he does take with the pawn
there could be tactics related to knight
e4 gaining a tempo at a critical moment
so instead
he takes with the pawn that was just
pure chest thought
and he is okay because at the end of the
day the king will just slide up to g7
protect those pawns and the open g file
isn't enough for white to work with you
don't have
a queen and a rook and pieces starting
to checkmate the king so like i think
there's a good
decision by fedor say up there it's such
a good point and i like to say it's
sometimes how chess knowledge has
evolved right robert over the years we
see that there's
the dynamic factors of opening up the
king and in some cases
a quick switch where the king gets
active in the end game make g takes f6
not just a necessity but a better move
and oh my god hikaru goes to queen sac
town
but is this a good decision i don't
think so look at carl's time by the way
i didn't even notice that he was the one
in more time trouble
and with the d4 pawns hanging knight if
it covers the e1 score there's no
checkmate
but it felt like for a moment there
black should be doing well i saw the
eval bar
in black's favor and now it's about
level uh this is going to be a difficult
one to assess
i like the two rooks though danny now
that the smoke is cleared i agree let's
bring back the analysis board because
we'll probably analyze just a little bit
of that queen sack um but again
quickly ricardo played queen a6 having
calculated
this idea of sacrificing the queen for
two rooks
where was the better approach for black
i don't know but it wasn't queen before
and in the end hecarim seems to be
coordinating and figuring it out despite
time pressure look at those two rooks
about to do
dirty work on the back rank all right
but here
f5 is good it gives the king square but
that's what you need to do two rooks are
better than a queen
because they can team up on a square an
f7 is that square
it's a light square that bishop can't
help in its defense so it looks like
this is hikaru's game right now
and uh unless something goes really
drastically wrong oh
that's i thought it was something going
wrong too what happened there
he got he hit both rooks in a row but
hikaru saw more than either
and rookie five hit the queen in return
and now he can bring the rook oh he
actually had rook takes e6 there too but
he didn't see it
yeah he's oh okay but there's no way
that king walks uh
survives that walk in the park and rook
g7 forcing rook h4
that's an owie yeah and uh and hikaru
does do
what he came to do which is strike first
here in the same game let's bring back
the analysis board we'll take a quick
look
at how that one finished again the
threat that was unstoppable was rook h4
mate
but the federal saves credit if he sits
tight
there's threats of rook f4 rook takes e6
is on the agenda
there really weren't a lot of options
right robert yeah now can we just go
back quickly to that bishop
uh before this hitting both rooks what
vision by hikara because i'm freaking
out like oh he blundered
but he saw that he had this rook e5 move
and black's queen is forced away from
all of the
uh action and that just goes on to win a
clean game there
yeah and uh i'm not sure what else black
could have done here to maintain a
closer
a closer level uh the computer seems to
think maybe keep the queen
on the diagonal is a little more awkward
but i'm with you that it'll probably
work
the hook on d6 gets trapped what
the rook on d6 gets trapped after queen
b7 oh wait oh my god
that's the idea that's crazy
yeah nobody's saying that would just if
the rook goes here probably bishop e7
like gosh what a hard move to see
and then after rookie eight just to
finish this off i think there's queen d7
and after rook b8 is finally bishop g6
yeah what a ridiculous oh my god that's
why it's a computer we don't
i don't have the computer moves in front
but that that's nuts robert and you saw
it well but it's funny is white's
probably still
holding that position if no longer
better but federal state did not see it
as we said he moved the queen away
and hikaru does the job we'll stay right
here on the analysis board and
remind everybody real quick of the
opening we missed because we were
focused on reviewing that
what do we have here robert we had a
queen's indian slash catalan
opening ikaro plays into mainline stuff
with dc4 stop me if there's something
you want to chat about
not really the bishop on g2 being a very
powerful piece and that's why hikar
brings the bishop out
the way he does is to challenge that
bishop on g2 you do not want to allow
that to sit
there and dominate we've seen kramnik do
that for so many years it's not
very pleasant for black yeah 100
this is a kind of a typical catalan you
you fee encountered the bishop so to
speak by hand rather than the
traditional b6
and bishop b7 but this is all very equal
stuff and
i believe something i've seen these two
guys played before i uh
i don't i don't make a habit of just
sitting and watching players on the
chess.com server but i feel like this
opening
is going to be repeated today we know
federosayev likes a catalan
and look at this idea here he gives up
the b7 pawn with this nice c5 tactic
exposing the pin on the d2 bishop
who's better here i'm starting like
black's position i think this is a
hikaru nakamura at his best
because uh that move rook a to d8 that
he played ignoring the fact that b7 was
hanging which looked
really bad honestly because the knight
in a6 stalls in trouble he just saw
a little bit uh further ahead and right
now we're at a position
after the bishop captured instead of you
know black would play c6 for example to
stop the fish from capturing but here
you trade knights c5 will fall the rook
on d2 is so powerful
you're going to control the only fully
opened file by bringing your f
to d8 it just seems like all of the
pluses in the position
are for black and white is temporarily
you know
just looking okay with the opposite
bishops but you just don't have a plan
well that line i was just showing with
knight e4 bishop e4 the question i would
ask you is should black take here or
just maybe
or honestly even f5 is a move right you
gain a tempo and then win c5 actually
yeah five actually is probably good not
hanging h7 i
totally forgot about that pawn i wasn't
aware of the entire board they are so
focused on how good it looked for black
but f5 looks
like a good starting point for black not
being aware of the whole board makes me
think maybe you should do a lesson
series on full board awareness
i don't think you're uh you know hinting
at anything are you maybe
maybe not uh use chess.com lessons
for all your uh all your chess
improvement needs by the way
um anyway jokes aside queen f6 coming
with
the c5 pawn hanging means that f2 will
be under pressure
he is giving up h7 by the way i really
like that move
this is this is risky to go for this one
now black is threatening g6 to win the
bishop b2
is falling oh my gosh and bishop takes
c5
yeah that's a pawn that you really want
to take but you understand the
consequences are too great so bishop
takes h7
will lose white material and now i think
the move that should be played
i don't have the lines from it i see the
bar is about level but i'm having a hard
time finding moves which means something
like maybe
rook to a2 just to it's a disgusting
looking move but it protects the pawn on
b2
and i don't think you can afford to give
up b2 while your rook on e1 is hanging
you can't move your rook from e1 because
then e2 is hanging
i see all these problems so i'm just
looking at rook a2 and
hoping yeah that this doesn't look good
rook takes beats for this but rook b2
and bishop b1 is coming by the way funny
line if you played rook a2 i wonder if
rook takes b2 was still possible because
the bishop takes e1 i only had that idea
by the way you described the position so
it's definitely clear that federal state
have had a lot to figure out so
hard to hold it against him now we'll
see if hikaru can convert on
what are the tactics i why not just take
and take what's he waiting for
there we go uh i'm not sure
bishop takes e1 i don't see a response i
mean the rook on b2 is safe and sound
he's just
okay so maybe this is what he was
thinking about he wasn't thinking about
okay do i play rook b2 do i take the
rook of course he saw that
but he was trying to figure out the
response afterwards so he didn't have to
spend time at that moment and that's
something that we know
hikaru does better than anybody is
figuring out these moments of when you
should
spend your time and when you should
force your opponent uh
clock to start ticking but you know
making the move and i think that's what
he was going for there
it's somebody who said that because it's
it's you and i say this a lot it's not
taking your time it's time management
right in a position where he knows he's
holding the cards
he makes sure he's super precise and
then he can rattle off several moves
so in the critical moment that his
opponent wasn't thinking of in his head
now that person has to think about it on
their time and
it sounds silly but it's a super
important thing to develop in terms of
your own maturity and discipline as a
chess player
to manage your clock and don't be in a
rush just because the moves are obvious
um just for example if it caro had
rattled off that whole idea and then
paused to think
him and his opponent would both be
thinking about the same position instead
the mystery
makes fedor say i'm not sure where the
game is going
exactly and well this position here it
is a rook for a bishop and one pawn
there's actually quite a bit of
compensation for white
white's king on g2 not going to be in
too much danger unless somehow
you can get a useful check and take over
the second or the last rank
the good thing for white is that the
bishop one b5 is so powerful
it's defended by a pawn that's good news
it defends both a4
and c6 on the queen side it also comes
back to defend upon an e2
it's doing everything so now the
question is how does black
break through the position is great you
are better you're up a rook for just a
bishop and an h pawn that's not relevant
just yet
but how do you win the game and not just
stand better
yeah it's a great question and
originally my plan was going to be to
suggest just move the queen and
double the rooks on the second ring but
as you highlighted the bishop
is already kind of prepared for that
right it's really not clear
this is one of those positions where the
eval bar can throw you off yes black is
materially better but
lack of a plan is uh
super hard to deal with for black
and we'll see hikar brings the pawn up
to g5 one thing that he could try to go
for it and that's why h3 was played out
if he can get g4 it's not double the
rooks in the h file
that h2 pawn was on a dark square so he
puts the pawn on h3
not allowing his pawns to become totally
backward on that side of the board
and danny let me give you a bunch of
free moves obviously you're not gonna
just take my bishop and move away
but some you know realistic moves what
is black's plan what are you gonna do if
i gave you three free moves right now
right
let's go to the analysis board maybe
analyze it a little bit and figure it
out because
okay so let's say white just sits to
prove the point that
robert's making and i don't know forget
what the eval bar is saying our point is
even things like this it's not totally
clear i mean this this would blunder for
example it would under the rook
but the point is even if you do obvious
things it's not clear where you're
better right how do you make progress
here
in this position we see that f3 played
by federal save also not bad because
here's what he's saying
this pawn is already guarded i got you i
got your back
right the bishop is taking care of all
the little guys here
it certainly is i'm really trying to
come up with
a plan perhaps it involves trading a
pair of rooks but
if you trade a pair of rooks then you
can't gang up on a pawn
so that's the downside the good thing if
you can imagine the rook on c1 the rook
on d8
being off the board now you have to
watch out for rook takes b5 sacrifices
and the eight pawn going through so
that's in the back of my mind i'm not
quite sure that
uh hikara can make that work but those
are the some of the ideas that you
should be considering
no it's a great point uh just to always
be aware that when you're up the
exchange you have the ability to give it
back
if the chance uh it comes so
rook to c3 black is maybe now going to
try to switch to the first rank
um how does fedocide deal with that
rook to c5 oh nice he's going to move
the bishop from from b5 to hit a5 and
ricardo says no thank you
yeah i guess exchanging the rooks allows
that black king just walk into the game
which is why federer says keeping a rook
on the board but your idea
of going for a checkmate honestly by
bringing the rooks down to the first
rank that could be
quite scary for white to deal with yeah
just to illustrate what could happen
forget the the popularness of the
whether that's likely
but f4 eventually comes and the point is
that move holds e3 from escaping
it holds g3 so if you're wondering what
is kind of the abstract
mating net in fact uh that abstract idea
was stopped by fedo sam
precisely because it might become a
reality um
but this is what akara wants right when
you have the rooks you want these kind
of moves being made the more pawns
advance the more potential targets are
created the more the rook can flex
for sure and it's very difficult for
white because that rook on c3 could
never find an open file
and here's no exception rook g3 i play
rook g1 check i trade off the rook so
federal save needs to somehow get his
rook to attack either c7
or a5 but that car has stopped it
completely by putting the rook on a1
keeping the bishop frozen on b5
and now the rook on c3 can't swing over
to g3 at least not yet
yeah hicaro can play a little tickle if
he wants only 18 seconds
for fedo sev almost 30 for recaro we
haven't talked too much about the time
these guys have been close to level in
both games so far
um oh wait but now
yeah now uh nice both ropes a net is
ensuing i feel like we're about to have
a fanciful rook finish here
fancy feet look at that bishop f1
was nice couldn't take it because the
rook hung everybody
that's funny you know it's a good try
the position is losing so he went
for uh just a little trick not working a
car too strong and
this is going to be hikaru's second win
in a row
yep and it was it was a nice hold there
for quite
some time by fedo save now the bishop
will fall on king g1 the move is rook a1
winning the bishop and sophosaev resigns
but
robert i feel like there's deja vu here
right you and i have done a lot of
hikaru nakamura matches
and sometimes we have games like that
where like that was really close the
opponent played well and and we're
we're heading into time pressure and
then all of a sudden
like i can't even point back to exactly
the turning moment but hikaru walks away
with the dub
and i you know i said i'll move 15 or so
that was the best of hikaru nakamura i
just saw the way he was playing
and i've had the pleasure and the pain
honestly of playing hikaru
for many years now uh first over the
board and of course online
and you know you recognize the way that
he plays over time and
there depends on the match situation
depends on the event
but that is just vintage hikaru just
getting tactical
not giving his one any chances freezing
his opponents pieces in ways that they
can't improve their position
and then just maneuvering in a way that
uh increases your advantage right karu
is in very good shape i would say the
first game he wasn't
um maybe as precise as he needed to be
federsev was
getting out of it any car was a bit slow
on the clock but
then i do believe that fedo saves
connection issues
caused hikaru some psychological
problems a car does not want to win
because of some internet connection
issue so i think game one that was for
both sides
something that you know you forget about
it it was a victory for a car of course
good for the scoreboard but
we won't see that type of play happen
again here's a knight on e5 to prove
that point
well and and good to know knock on wood
so far we hopefully won't see internet
connectivity issues again for fedor save
because since that first game
we haven't really seen any problems by
the way shout out to all the subs we
have coming in your support of the
channel
means the world honestly it's why these
events are possible you and our premium
members we appreciate it and
throw us your prime we have another
primetime smackdown match coming up
at the break um and uh
and uh subscribers will get to watch it
in full with no commercials so
all right 95 played this is one of those
early moves that has
it wasn't as popular in the traditional
or you know renaissance years of the
queen's gambit if you will like it was
moving a piece twice breaking opening
principles
but white goes for this stuff a lot now
as sort of a catapult to f4 coming in
and launching the potential of a
kingside attack um
what do you think about this response to
it with dtx c4
i think that fidosev was getting
concerned he was burning quite a bit of
time
and i liked 95. i think that when your
opponent placement was like h6 and it
plays a bit slower
you can just hop into the center and i
like the decision there by hikaru to
take with the knight instead of
developing the bishop and recapturing
the pawn he moves his knight a third
time
and the large reason why is when your
opponent has less space
you do not want to trade their pieces
off and the knight on d7 cramps the
bishop on c8
now the d file opens but i do think that
fedor save isn't
in bad shape even if so far hikaru has
i think a slight little pull out of the
opening
well we've seen knight d6 check to
gobble the bishop parrots
probably not really that big of a deal
uh the knight can be traded and despite
the dark squares black can quickly offer
a queen trade and
and equalize uh in the end game but it
is the bishop here and we know how
hammer would feel about the bishop here
right
um let's bring up the analysis board
real quick just to show
what robert was talking about h6 was
played and because of that loss of tempo
so to speak hikaru doesn't have to be
asked to gain a tempo himself with
knight e5
and dc4 like you said you keep the
pieces on the board when your opponent
has less space don't let them trade it
now c5 takes takes and we're seeing that
hikara will not waste time trying to get
the bishop here just plays bishop e2
and i expect him to castle right after
fedor say if he's just done so
and back down to one bar hopefully that
fixes itself it does seem like it
you know it goes back to normal um but
his position is okay
right now with the black pieces you
traded off two pawns
you have some open lines that you can
work with uh the issue that
can potentially happen is you look at
this knight on c4 and you start worrying
yourself
about it getting to d6 because when
knight d6 happens
you win a bishop but i'm going to put
win in air quotes
because do you really want that bishop
on c8 danny you know better than anyone
how i feel about that bishop on c8
yeah i showed the dark square bishop
would not be what you want
to use robert's air quotes this would be
a problem
on the dark squares but uh giving up the
light square bishop would probably be
fine okay so knight d6 is played
i expect to move like queen e7 right
this move a double attacks the knight
and kind of forces the trade so that
then you've given up a bad piece for a
good piece there
well federal staff plays 95 even better
in terms of a double attack
the same trade happens and and i like
federal state's position here this is uh
the best i think middle game that the
big fish has had all day
it looks to be the case for sure even
though white has the
two bishops advantage that i think we
talk about that so much that people
think is
when i get the two bishops i am better
definitely not
here though and the reason why is look
at how active black's pieces are you
have
a rook on the open c file a knight on e5
uh you can play b4 at some moment i
would not play that
at least not unless i'm provoked because
that opens up the light square bishop
on the entire diagonal uh what i will
say though
is it's not easy for black to come up
with a plan here and it feels like white
is relying on the fact that hey if i can
trade some pieces
in the long term the bishop hair will be
superior to the knights
it's a good point because even we've had
this so many times where you know the
optics look great
but where's the ability to improve it
the long-term factors might favor the
person who has a piece that you lack
and in this case you mentioned b4 being
risky but also white has a4
as a common plan here these positions he
doesn't go for a4 now
kind of slow jams this he's going to
take his time
um but it doesn't change that the
long-term light squares could be a
problem for pedo-save
i think so and i asked this question
pretty much
uh every day what is black's plan if i
gave you three free moves and i'm not
quite seeing it
whereas for white i see plenty of
different options uh bishop e1 i was
going to mention rook to c1 can happen
knight a2 is a common remaneuvering of
the piece
opening up your bishop on e1 for some
longer diagonal and
giving you the option to play a4 or
knight b4 so it's a flexible approach
for white
and black on the other hand making
logical moves just not
consequential ideas yeah
makes sense um and he does answer a
little bit of your question
if you gave me three moves what would i
do apparently i'm going to double on the
c
file if i'm pedal save but that's always
a good question to ask yourself it's not
just a
sort of abstract one there from grand
master robert hess
if you ask yourself what your next three
moves are not fantasy chess and find a
way to coordinate
often that is suggesting something you
should go for all right 95 but
i like just bishop f3 at some point i'm
threatening knight before my bishops are
coming out and you're right it feels
like white has more chances to improve
than black
and that hikara phase says can i still
go knight to b4
because i've ruined my pawn structure
sure but a takes b4
makes my rook a glorious piece on a1 he
goes wow knight back to c3 instead
yeah that's surprising
just gonna repeat now maybe he'll play
bishop f3 first if he really was
irritated about that to prevent knight
d5
and go back to his plan but a funny
thing is is that
moving the knight also kind of prevented
this knight from moving because of the
threat here so if you don't
maybe federal safe has plans for a
knight at five knights c4 right so he's
not
quite sure what to do here and he's now
he's under a minute i'm with you i was
about to mention the clock as well
it's we're not used to seeing hikaru
down so much time
and that you know you got to give it
credit to fedoceof who despite losing
two games
he's still in his element he's just
playing good moves and doing it
relatively quickly
very much in a hikaru nakamura style but
ikaru i like what he just did there he
goes knight to a2
he recognizes hey this position was
actually good for me and fedor save
also realized the same and did not play
knight d5 once more
the second time around we're gonna get
knight b4 i expect him to take what the
bishop he does and now
after the queen moves i think just
bishop f3 no a4
he says no no no dan the bishop's right
where it belongs buddy let's undermine
and make some targets
and this is a tough choice here for
fedocerv you can capture on a4 which
most of the time is the incorrect
decision because you give
access to attack your weak pawn on a6 uh
but here
there could be some tactics along rook
c1 ideas because of the real takes on a4
you lose control of your first rank
so i would think about politics a4 i
wouldn't want to play it and that's why
he does not play it
braids yeah that's interesting maybe he
should have though look at that move
bishop he won he keeps the pieces on the
board
but maybe maybe it wasn't his best
because now you can't actually take this
pawn everybody
um and just to show you couldn't take it
before
because if you did the the pin would win
um but i'll say of keeping this thing
leveled the b
pawn will it prove to be a target or a
strength if you can keep it on the board
and get some counter play you'll be all
right but
ricardo ricardo's gonna make it really
hard to keep that pawn
the b4 pawn is very bad for black in an
end game but it's very good for black in
the current dynamic
because look at that bishop on e1 it's
just staring at that pawn can't capture
it but in endgames then white's king
will just run over to the queen side and
start trying to attack that pawn so
i like what feather saves doing at this
moment and
watch out for some kind of bishop c3 for
white because the rook on b8 is not
protected
so bishop c3 could be a possible move
ooh it's a great idea
take advantage of the pin hit the rook
on v8 but federal state is working it
watch the queen at night get surgical up
in these light squares you got to watch
out
he plays the rook back i expect queenie
for check at some point
that'll save up more than a minute on
the clock this is a rare situation to
see hikaru in such self-induced time
pressure
yeah and look at fedo say he is locked
into his screen right now trying to
figure out
a way forward it's looking good for him
the king on g2
in worse shape than the king on g7 he
plays knight g4
what is it threatening is there some
kind of attack
not quite figuring it out here
queen f6 retreats
i like b3 you're being patient but
notice federal save has put the pressure
on f2
hard to believe it you don't really want
to part ways with the light squares here
right that's an instructor point you're
taking a knight gives it you lose that
bishop you lose control over the light
squares
so i would say here for fedocero he's
trying to figure out can i do something
with the
double works on the c file but you're
offering a rook trade if you move the
bishop out the way and maybe then
he's not seeing a way to continue
pressing forward i
like the look of his position i just
don't see how you
knock black out here
okay now he ends up retreating tonight
which just feels awkward and we're
getting into mutual time pressure now
between players
you're right position go ahead no you go
ahead
oh no b4 hangs you go ahead whoa and if
bishop takes before rook takes c7
but then a5 is hanging at the end of
this whole thing so
too much yeah
i was going to take on c7 first take an
a5 but then white has stolen a pawn
but i see that somehow going to get the
better of this
and hikaru i don't want to say swindles
because
it was also concrete but the way that
converted was uh
was awkward and look at that move takes
advantage if you take e2 i get the
knight
oh but now you lose b3 okay so we should
probably have a draw here
turns out queen a7 was not the best
approach
and is fedo say of trying to play for a
win because he did not trade queens
there
and i think it's the right call he is a
knight against a bishop we talk about
this all the time knights can go from
color complex to color complex bishop
stuck
on its diagonal so i actually think that
playing for a win is not a
bad shot i agree and even if objectively
this should be a draw you see the
computer puts up the donut over there
all zeroes but
from a practical perspective with humans
the knight holds all the cards when
everything is on one side of the board
flex from one color to another see if
you can poke some weaknesses loose
um not doing it yet but
still time i think he kind of played
tickle there robert to gain a little bit
of time on the increment
he did and he in what g4 was queen
before check
oh he missed that yeah oh
that was not ideal no sir but you know
what it is
ideal in terms of defense again light
square bishop you can control the dark
squares and h8
corner doesn't match that bishop just
the thing i'm thinking about right now
not gonna fool robert has twice in the
same 24 hours he will
he will mention that early for those who
uh watched lavon
aronian versus mvl yesterday you get
that inside joke and i love you more
than others
um we're likely gonna have a draw as
robert said
even if somehow you converted this
knight at this point could probably sack
for the pawn as long as you can ensure
h4 h4 play h4 right now he should have
played h4
make the pawn come to the corner no he
didn't do it any lost in time oh my god
no
oh wow oh his head's in his hand
oh my god all the applauding
he defended so well oh
wow that's that is a heartbreaking way
to start your
your upset campaign against the number
one overall seed in hikaru nakamura
to the batcave we go we gotta look at it
here we go
omgs are snaps it's a draw it's a drawn
position
but he loses on time but robert's point
is still a good one if you just play h4
here look at this
h4 brilliant by fedo sayev knight check
and sack
so even though he he loses on time and
it still feels unfair
robert's not wrong that the heads-up
play still would have been better by
fedo sayev
force the pawn to the corner sacked the
knight and this is a draw because the
bishop cannot force the king out it's a
theoretical position
but dude robert what a heartbreaker
man and for fedo say of
he went for it right he could have made
a droid any point
but he was trying to win he blundered
with e4 while trying to win
and he still could have held but one of
the things i'll say danny
is when you're well ahead on the clock
sometimes you don't even realize how
much time trouble
you're in because he was up a minute for
a large portion of that game
now it's a scramble and you just think
that you have more time than you have
with the increment and
things go south but danny we're in this
new game here
oh man we're getting another one of
these italians did we
did we go back to yesterday are we in a
time travel booth here and aronian
aronian mvl called they want their
opening back
i did not give maxine nearly enough crap
for that for that
over and over italian but i want to be
like hey dude you're french not italian
did you get the memo and i think he
would have
rolled his eyes and been like danny this
is why we don't talk anymore
bad danny jokes
but uh anyway we are in an italian and
we know that
jokes aside it is a very in vogue
opening at the highest levels of chess
partly because of the flexibility that
robert and i talk about a lot both sides
have pawn structures that you can do
something with right it's not a
symmetrical
deadlock position which is why it's so
attractive because top players
want to be able to outplay their
opponent they don't want to just have
forced computer prepared draws
right and i would say that with the
bishop pair
in this position it's not so clear the
light square bishop which is
uh white is missing at the moment that
that bishop on g4 is going to anything
other than take on f3
but even the threat of taking on f3
could potentially be problematic
for white if it undermines the center
it's not clear if that's the case
but that's just one of the things you
want to focus in on
well we see carl thinking again he's
been the slightly slower player
at least in the first stages of the game
despite him being up 3-0 on the
scoreboard
um i think you made a great
psychological point that sometimes the
problem with being so upon the clock
is you lose that sense of urgency the
guy that's been under 20 seconds for the
last 10 minutes is very aware of how
much time he has right
um and uh i hope phil save adjusts from
that
all right h3 now wait
speaking of undermining uh
i'm looking at a conversation jacob
uh what i guess then queen takes f6 but
i've been looking at hikara's facial
expressions because
at least he knows there's something
super rare hit car knuckle board number
19.
he was smiling and looking at the
ceiling it's always okay
go back to the camera just i know the
catalog it's always the
the look at the opening look at the
opening i'm not actually thinking right
now but people love this
normally it's that hey car nakamura
number seven that was a
what is going on here that was number
19. you rarely see that everyone you're
welcome it's funny because people when
you say you have a catalog of hikara
facial expressions
they think you just you know make things
up they don't realize that you actually
have a full-on
book of a car facial expression i've had
i got a lot of time on my hands a car
and i've been hanging out since we were
i was 10 he was eight things got real on
the basketball court i'll tell you that
um and uh
anyway c5 okay but hicaro did get the
best of that exchange no jokes and he
took advantage of the d4 pressure that
you called
yeah c5 is a nice move you have double
pawns why not try to undouble them
challenge white center and free up some
important squares that d4 pawn goes to
d5
give me that e5 square for my knight the
queen of f6 also stares at the pawn on
b2
things look to be going hikaru's way for
a fourth straight game
yeah playing well bishop takes c5
um the b2 pawn is under fire
as you said so he defends it but now
here comes 95
right 95 i guess there's
f4 just for the time being that
does allow white to hang in here it
feels like white's position should be
on the verge of collapsing but you have
to be precise and that's why hikaru
wisely spending his time plus a4
look at that we talk about the concept
of full board awareness he knows that 95
is something he wants to play
but first let's try to open up the queen
side for my rook on eight
it's a great move and even though i was
teasing earlier about a lesson that
robert's working on full board awareness
it actually i love how you say that
right because that's like such a good
position to train where you're like
all your focus has been about this and
you've got the dark square attention but
you take a moment to reflect on the full
board opportunity
to use your strengths everywhere right
and a4 is a great move
to create that kind of chance and while
it's an advanced concept i think full
board awareness is something people
should develop very early in their chess
kind of careers right
yeah absolutely and that's why i try to
remind everybody including myself
of different ideas in that last game
remember that the bishop doesn't match
the corner
that may seem irrelevant because there
were all these other pawns on the board
but it actually played a role and that
is what happens in chess you want to
sort of forecast where the game could
potentially go
and make the most of your opportunities
and here look at that move
rook a5 it wasn't just about the weak
pawn he opened up the fifth rank so his
rook can
just jump from a5 over to the king side
and
attack the king so preemptively federer
says i don't want any part of that check
i'm gonna march my king over to f1 i'm
gonna get out of josh let's bring back
the analysis board because seriously
robert is rocking the full board
awareness moments accidental teaching
moments by robert hess
um a4 boom and it's not just about the
double pawn dude
it's about rook a5 the flexing of the
full board
now you double rooks and white is just
struggling here with weaknesses you'll
have to deal with here
the potential over here on the king side
i love it when you teach look at that
queen e6 hitting the rook on c4 and the
pawns the pawn on h3
ouch this is a model game by hikar right
now yes
he shows the problems when white plays
standard looking moves that seem like
all is
good and fine and then you are met with
this
c5 break that he played then he pushes a
pawn up the board yeah then he just
created problems on both flanks
and fedocere's pieces were not
coordinated well enough to deal with
everything and
the game is not over right here h3 falls
okay it's not checkmate at least not yet
so you can continue playing here but
it's not looking good because material
is now even
white's pawn structure is worth worse
excuse me with double pawns in the f
file and the a
file and look at this rerouting the
knight instead of focusing on the a pawn
let me bring my knight into f4 with
check your king is being hunted
no seriously and for the record i
highlighted that idea before he carl
played it
i saw it happen i knew you would
no kidding uh yeah the king has got his
full running shoes on right now
um
notice that hiccaro not as down on time
as he has been in some of the other
games in this match so really just kind
of finding his form here and
like you said it would be a shock to me
this was
you know not to take anything away from
artemyev
or even from hikaru the other way but i
felt like this match might be the one
that was a little closer
um of the of the you know the number one
versus you know the lowest
number one and number two versus lower
seats today right but right now hikaru
is like hey
i heard the cry i know people said that
federal save is a match for me but i'm
bringing my a game today
he really has thus far and it's
impressive because federsev
is a monster but hikaru i just
i'm noticing it in his play today he he
clearly cares
and he just brought his best blitz self
i i'm really liking the way he's playing
and i actually don't think it's an
overreaction
you could see the quality of the games
he's not
being bothered by kind of oh this pawn
i need to take that back and he's
playing very aggressively tactically
and he's not giving fedo say of many
chances at all
well we've got more than 24 000 of you
still on twitch we've had a lot of
viewers all day
8 000 plus of you on youtube you see all
the chat rooms being super positive
super focused on the chest we really
appreciate it
and uh and thanks for being here all
right rook takes a3
sacking the exchange to finish off the
j.o.b here look at that he's going to
win the f2 pawn
open up the second rank and ask
questions later
this is by the way he even has this move
queen e5 i'm not sure if that's the
finishing touch
but you got to be thinking about it a
quick flip to a1
i like it you're you're looking
everywhere he just says
i'm going to just just gotta see what
the
no no good okay nevermind
one of those moments where yeah it looks
good let's not actually focus on it but
no it's a good idea let's say it was
good it
looks pretty good to me i'll give you
that but the problem for
white right now is your king is still
out in the open black's queen and brook
are hitting the f2 square
uh okay so how does he gonna settle on
the draw
maybe he feels like he let the attack go
nope no that was brigade the car was
like
i i don't think that black can get in
any danger in the near future so there's
no reason and look what's the age was
that h1
become a queen they might notice how the
geometry of the board was so perfect the
queen was guarding the only weakness so
fetishive has to exchange it and open
the board
now the night blocks the e-file though i
wonder if you might consider taking yeah
he does
hoping for a perpetual check that
probably doesn't exist
well rook b5 rook h5 would be checkmate
but of course black gets a move so the
queen g one check
will probably there's also rook b8 just
to force an exchange if you want
oh nice did you realize the que i was so
focused on not getting checkmated that i
thought i need to give you some checks
to be immediate but rook b8 that's uh
a nice little move there but okay
um yeah okay queen d6 i have the same
idea i was thinking about bringing the
queen back to one of these diagonals
which is going to make it super hard for
white but he's using the fact that he's
two
squares d3 and g6 so you can stop one
but not the other and the h pawn is now
free to run yeah this is a
problem howie a file problems i got him
queen f1 is actually the more accurate
approach
because of queen c1 you have rook a1 you
have picaro finds it
now you have between a1 and rook a2 or
this idea
and soon you could probably even trade
off the queens and win a rook end game
but i
probably wouldn't venture into that
right now yeah he checks he'll check
back on a8 no
quinty wanted to save me oh queen d
wants me
yeah you said it first i give you credit
not not
necessarily the cl the cleanest finish
off to what was a model game but he did
finish off a model game and carl
nakamura is up
four games here wow not exactly what we
were expecting
um and the day is young we have a lot of
time left in this match
40 minutes in the five minute segment
but hikaru is flexing
he's playing superb chess and there are
times when hikar is the first to
criticize his own play he'll win a match
by 10 games
and then like oh i played badly and
sometimes you know
he's just all chess players they are
trying to be perfect in their moves but
sometimes he
also means it and i think right now he's
likely has to be proud of his play i
mean it's not perfect nobody plays
perfect chess
but i have been very impressed by his
play and for defenders
of credit he has put up some pretty
tenacious defense
he just needs to get a good position and
just working it feels like he's never
really even had an advantage
in the games thus far agreed it's it's
uh
as it hasn't been a single game where
you felt like a car lost control and
again he's better as white
uh andrew lee in the chest tv chat says
this is better than the nba
you're darn right it is what does the
nba stand for
national boring association
oh skadoosh all right oh my goodness
danny yeah yeah
my son's with the big chris paul j
crowder pickups playoffs here become
phoenix suns baby
um yeah i can't say the same for my new
york knicks so i'm just gonna
move on back to the chest so anyway
back to the same line we saw earlier
let's bring up the analysis board just
because it's
now becoming a theoretical lesson we
should always take advantage of that if
you're just joining us hikaru employed
this opening the last time he was white
we had the same moves played
until here after a6 and a4 this was
different previously fedo saif had
chosen to move c5
and now we're in again a very
traditional kind of uh slav
queen's gambit accepted kind of
structure this move knight a2 exposing a
bishop who's kind of lost his way now
that the knight isn't pinned
and uh white does indeed pick up the
bishop pair here and has a small edge
yeah and freder for a second time
has the knights against the bishop but
he has control first
of the c file but this is the problem
when you're facing bishops is look at
that bishop on a3
staring down to that pawn on d6 and the
knight on d7
we talk about superfluous pieces the
knight of d7 where does it want to go to
hey maybe we'd like to go to f6
oh wait there's already a knight on that
square so black's pieces aren't able to
press forward whereas white's initial
position
you already see direct threats issue on
e2 hitting a6
bishop on a3 hitting d6 they're slicing
through the
position and black is just kind of
cramped and stuck
yeah yeah well set and when you have
less space as robert said your pieces
are kind of wrestling each other for the
same squares
the one advantage you would say long
term i mean less space a lot of times
the pawns are solid and protecting each
other but when white also already has
the bishop pair
you already have weaknesses to focus on
yeah you just feel
um feel like this is going to be tough
and yeah if this continues today this is
a you know a reminder i think sometimes
people see
hikaru nakamura being the streamer that
he is doing multiple tasks right he's
playing and streaming and commentating
and thanking his sponsors and modding
chat right this is this is full vintage
hikaru nakamura fully focused not
streaming no commentary don't forget
why he's the two-time defending scc
champion
right you know most of the time he's
playing well and
even when he's streaming and doing all
these things he's still playing great
chess
but this is really a different car right
now yeah and
um i i feel for fedo sev because i can
only imagine how difficult it is to be
his opponent when a car is on form and
right now i think this is a position
where white is better i don't see
a clean way to press forward and win the
game
so if ferocious can hold here he needs
something to latch onto
some semblance of confidence and
this is i think a game where if he could
survive it
maybe get a win somewhere he can try to
mount a comeback even though
the odds are looking quite long yeah and
here you've got this
french slash hero khan bishop you know
what benny watts said right all pawns no
hope right makes uh makes jack a dull
boy over here
and uh this is why white is just clearly
better now you made a good point now now
how do you convert where's the beef
hicaro's got to prove it
but the dark square dominance is real
and uh but let me ask you what's the
plan here
teach me bobby hess how does white how
does white make make progress
i would play queen c2 provoking g6 and
then probably
play queen to d2 and then try to knight
g4 and just
i'm going to use both oh okay
look at how you just work that with no
diggity you brought the queen up that's
what ricardo did
well f5 was the response that same idea
you had
using the light squares for checkmate
threats everyone if you missed the memo
now you're undermining the defender of
said square right
that was an only move quinn f7 you
couldn't move the knight and you
couldn't allow knight takes f6 to happen
so queen f7 was played 95
if takes takes now you have to move the
knight allowing queen f7
plus it opens up and puts pressure on
the c file here
i mean just he he's turning a tactical
position
into a also a positional one he's
recognizing it doesn't have to be about
checkmate only
i can fix my isolated pawn while
attacking my opponent's knight and
removing that defender
but he goes back to g4 interestingly
enough he says i
you know something about the 95 offering
the trade didn't speak to a place queen
d3
well and point out everyone this this
move is not just a move that allows a
check it allows checkmate
full board awareness as robert has said
many times today
so icaro is kind of sitting pretty and
that he can kind of play tickle he plays
this sort of just subtle what does this
even do move like a high-class waiting
move
because it's good to be king when you're
the dictator of the position sit on your
opponent and let them figure it out with
only two minutes on the clock
it's a good practical lesson to not feel
that you have to force things just just
sit tight
and as you know you're taught repeating
the position
can be a good thing when you're the side
with the advantage so
icard does it once he brings his knight
back g4 slides his queen to d3
and i guess federic plays a5 because
there was no other move that looked the
least bit appealing yeah
uh but you're looking at the whole board
give me a move give me a move
a5 played but it does have drawbacks
potentially now there's new issues to
worry about
you were focusing on the exact part of
the board i was also looking at
and not only is there queen b5 that
bishop on a3
can find its way to d6 and to c7 if the
queens get traded or that queen is
removed
from its defense so you have created a
permanent
setup on the queen side no longer can
black even think about playing b5
that squares under white's control and
you're just adding new weaknesses
to the position the knight comes back
the queen switches over
ricardo no longer interested in
repeating the knight and queen dance
brings pressure here with queen c3 to
the pin knight
so a funny idea robert just white have
time for things like
i know you don't i was going to say
bishop v3 bishop b5 to gang up on the
pin i forgot the knight actually defends
the queen
95 is a threat actually you're gonna
laugh but that was my exact
train of thought i was like hey can
white yeah that won't be one and
get into the game
oh i think did did he forget that too no
federal state is going to take here and
trade
but he carries saying the end game is
still great for me i have the bishop
pair
uh that pawn on b6 and the pawn a5 those
are
vulnerable pawns and the king will just
quickly run into the center for white
i actually like the decision yeah king
of two a very
kind of simple decision not the flashy
long diagonal checkmates we've been
envisioning
but but i guess you're right i mean the
end game after queen sees oh wow he
checks there a little inner meso to try
to
force a bad pawn structure but doesn't
really help black
i think bishop to e7 followed by d8 is
what the doctor ordered here
yeah that knight is going to have to go
to a8 to keep everything defended which
is
a pretty ugly move to have to play
i don't see a breakthrough just yet like
if
i see where we're going for bishop b7
bishop d8 that's all happening
so king f7 bishop go go to d8 and the
knight has to retreat to the corner
like white looks amazing but what now
yeah and and black can actually kick you
out next move but there are moves like
g5 you try to start opening things on
both sides of the board
icarl definitely agrees with you or he
wouldn't have paused to think
okay wait he's going for all the moves
he agrees with you too
and and yeah i guess if we're just
evaluating principle of two weaknesses
here everyone the problem is white has
both a two on one potential
asked pawn here you're a wizard harry
and also the target on the dark squares
over here so it just
makes black's tasks so tough to defend
and
white's one pawn on d4 stops black's
two pawns on e6 and d5 so the pawn
advantage of danny is highlighting
for the g h file those pawns are mobile
you can play g4 h4 h5 g5 just push those
pawns up
can't be stopped look at the 98 it is
trapped in the corner over there
but hey is that a knight or a donkey
oh whoa there's no way to sacrifice
there's no way this can work i don't
believe in it i think it's a good
practical try
but i i certainly don't believe in it
yeah the king is just marching over
tired of getting grinded decides to go
for a sack but
these pawns are easily stopped by the
two bishops the bishops are not like
knights when it comes to stopping past
pawns everyone
they do their job and they do it well so
um the bishop pair is wait
wait wait a second what does the car
just do with he didn't bring the bishop
back
i anticipated either bishop d6 or bishop
c1 now he's got himself in a bit of a
pickle here
it should still be winning but you you
can't ever take b3 without the queen
happening so now you got to do some
weird stuff
yeah that was a bit surprising because
you were saying bishop c1 and i thought
that was going to be the response just
stopping the pawns before they could
even
consider moving up the downside for
black but having pawn a2 is b3 is weaker
but look at this move knight c4 i don't
think you can take it
yeah you can't uh for the record
everyone it takes black would take and
then c3 check and the pawns coming
forward past pawns must be pushed
okay so king f6 is he is he claiming
that black can't do anything is that
what we're looking for i mean i guess
you could even play like g4 and h4
that's what he's saying he's like well
now what yeah the pawns can never push
right because if you play b2
you lose a2 so that's the good news for
white even though it looks scary the
king's in the corner
sorry oh no you're i wasn't looking at
the time you're right but the pawns
can't push so that means
that at some point white could play
bishop b5 to a4 or something like that
and try to get the pawn
yeah now it's now this should be a done
deal
yeah well now he's got himself in a
position too where the bishop is
guarding the diagonal as well
i thought he might play bishop b5 there
but i guess this is good
glad almost lost in time wait point
seconds
[Music]
a back breaker heartbreaker
oh my god that felt surprisingly good
i'm like a new man i feel like the dad
in incredibles who just got pulled apart
by the robot
and i know these exact references
because i've seen both incredibles and
incredibles 2
with your family so hey when you're
watching movies with the kids at the
wrenches right
oh man great time it's a great time
that's a great time
um you know who's not having a great
time right now it's not over federal
save oh my gosh
hikaru nakamura the beast right
um he's uh the last man
who's trying to get into the semi-finals
of course this match is far from over
the winner of this will fill out our
bracket
um and remember everybody it's already
set mark your calendars next weekend
you're spending it right here with these
two guys
hey robert air high five wait wait wait
wait wait wait
oh i mean i could do more you know
yeah i don't like
anyway so c5 car
snap oh snap
browser crashed you want to fix it
everything's okay i just i literally saw
austin app on screen i'm like ron
burgundy
oh snap i was like
at the same time like why are you
reading that out loud instead of fixing
the problem
when i get tired ron will read whatever
you put on the teleprompter everyone
go bleep yourself just.com could you
imagine
could you imagine if you could you know
you probably can't program the message
you get into an awesome app
that's what you should be so funny if
you could if it said like you know
something uh santiago native chung for
old wooden ship um anyway
pretty sure that's not what was said in
the movie but i appreciate you i i stole
two lines combining them together to
keep this thing pg i'm good at that
um yeah all right
wow well we are doing coverage of a
chess match but danny
i got to ask you something yeah
obviously hikaru was focused just on
federsev
but do you think in a sense he might be
sending a message to wesley so
because wesley knocked him out in the
skilling
uh champions tour event and west then
went on to beat magnus
that's who the winner of this match
plays in the semifinals
feels like there's a little bit of hey
yeah you know i i got this
right well i mean yeah i think kokoro
you know
we know this is going to be a year that
is going to come down to the wire no
idea who's going to win you and i have
said i mean
hikaru i think our unarguably has the
tougher side of the bracket he's facing
wesley so who's been in the finals
against him the last two years in the fc
in the sec without magnus playing taking
nothing away from mdl who's magnus's
opponent who i do believe by the way is
a stylistic
difficult opponent for magnus in some
ways we'll talk about that later i can't
wait for that match
but um yeah i think i think hikaru no
matter what has just shown up today
in full force and reminded people you
know he's an entertainer when he's
streaming and a great chess player
but he's also just a freak when he when
he's fully focused without the
distractions of commentary and
hey this is right now he's putting on a
show i don't know what else to say
he's winning again by the way as black
yeah he is and fedor
does not look very happy to be here i'm
happy to be here i'm having a great time
ferocious
nazi too i'm having a great time too
about to yeah i couldn't tell if you're
trying to do your seinfeld or what was
happening there you
were having a great time too if you just
wanted to make your boat
what go ahead no i just never know with
you if you're just becoming
you're kind of a child so i don't know
if you're going to puberty on camera
right now and
your voice is cracking but either way
it's fun
for fedo he is not enjoying himself
on the chessboard right now hikaru in
just like
honestly some of the best shape that
i've seen of him in
maybe i hate say ever but
when have you seen hit car play like
this like obviously there are moments
but it's everything it's been a little
while you know it's yeah this is uh
wow this is great form for hikaru you
know what it is
it's the chess.com hoodie i mean uh
chest chest bay i know you're listening
you could send a car
a message say that's your good luck
hoodie buddy don't forget it um
i see people using the uh the a word
in chess tv chat i do not believe there
will be an adoption i will go as far as
to say
no way okay hicaro is a is a monster
right now
don't even don't even whisper those
words in front of me with fedo say it
he's not gonna allow it
he'll find himself although i'm not
gonna lie this doesn't look like a good
start here in game six
this is no good blacks of a pawn
the rooks are for black are coordinated
in open files
the rook on a2 you probably should play
b3 just to make that rook feel
like it's uh a really yeah
it's useful in a way uh in the dark
squares and the king side not looking
very good
you can imagine if that bishop could get
from c5 over to b8 there would be a
checkmate
i don't know how i do that but i'll just
i'll pretend like that queen's not in
the way just put the bishop there
exactly or queen f if you before queen
see one was you know queen f4 bishop
yeah queen of four and bishop d6 was a
threat indeed
i don't know what to say anymore
what can white hope for here that's
that's
where i'm at right now let's think in
terms of what we can wish for
the holidays are coming up holidays are
here
uh what would you wish for hop on hop on
santa's knee here right i mean i don't
know if you're into that kind of thing
or
um uh no okay
i'll give you eight gifts you get to ask
for but you only get one
and then it's not even the one it's not
even the one you want you give the
pre-packaged
uh gift wrap thing over there that's
like a toy i didn't want
i know how this works yeah i know how it
works g5 played
uh fedo say of trying to mix it up but
you highlighted earlier the real issue
is just work on a2
um
not not not having a party whoa okay i
like this idea of g6 even just from a
practical perspective right fedex
is making a mess
the issue is he wishes it were more of a
mess because he's trying to
you know create a potential target here
that's the e6 pawn and
i i do agree with you though that you
need to do things like this you need to
give up upon
to say your knight on d4 now has to
remain there
protecting e6 but i don't think hikar is
upset to keep his knight on d4 it's such
a great square
but i will say the idea with knight e4
was also to open the c3 square for the
bishop rather than the knight and that
that does undermine
the centralized pony and and if this
knight is traded you know i'm just
looking at the light square
opportunities for fedo say up here the
long-term
light square chances so let's let's
analyze bishop to c3
see what is what does cecaro have on
that move
so you're clearly putting pressure on
the knight
on d4 you're trying to get through that
night to the
knight enough six i'm imagining at some
point some kind of e5 push but that
proves your point that if you ever play
e5 the light squares now
are super vulnerable and only white has
a light square bishop so i'm starting to
to buy it a bit more well i mean black
is
you know if we if we do the count black
is up what two three pawns here
i mean so materially yes it's tricky but
i just feel like from a practical
perspective
if we go back to when this kind of
approach started where he's like look
i'm not just going to sit tight and wait
for you to figure out
my dar squares i'm going to open up some
light squares it just makes sense
play towards your strengths and
okay this is a very good move by icaru
coming into f4 is a problem
yeah it's protecting g6
and e6 while attacking uh the queen of
course in the bishop one g2
so he'll just take back on c5 with the
queen
i think or dang we'll take with the pawn
to keep his knight
well protected yeah take the pawn
reinforce the knight even if g6 falls
you still have
knight f4 coming i mean he's thinking
about it though yeah i was going to say
because taking with the queen
exposes the rook's awkwardness because
now you're like hey dude remember that
rook on a2
not doing its normal job all day
right yeah
so rook a3 finally you know i got
excited
today junior get your rook in the game
you know i wasn't gonna use a billy
madison reference but um
sometimes you're not gonna frown upon it
either i
am frowny people just can't see it
but this rook on a3 trying to go to c3
queen c1 says not so fast take my knight
on d4 have fun with it i'll take your
bishop on e1
then i'll bring my rook down to help
deliver a checkmate
yep yeah i mean just to show everybody
robert's talking about this is a wee
bit of a problem note that even
defending g1 opens up a new checkmate so
the pressure is real fedo save has a
mess to figure out
and you have to settle on queen e1 okay
he goes queen e4
guarding attacking overwhelming
i wish i had insightful things to say
about this position it just
it doesn't feel good for white you need
five is is there moves like
you can't play knight c2 right away i
assume because we need six jack and
next year but yeah the problem is
there's more pressure coming to this
you can even trade queens right you have
a couple pawns yeah you could even
knight f5 by the way
because if you take c1 i take and the
knight guards e3
and if knight f5 takes e6 i put the king
on h7 and
still got problems um agreed
a queen b2 i guess uh overthinking it
well knight five works i mean queen e6
is just one pawn the king is
very safe on h7 yeah he pushes the e5
great move as well but again all
points made aside we are now in mutual
time pressure you got to give federal
save credit for that
but it's been a mess we'll see if he can
take advantage of it
you know it's funny we love our bishops
but white would could really use a
knight on g5 right about it yeah
the king on h7 how do you attack that
king unless you have a knight
there's just no way it's like the the
brick house what happened to the big bad
wolf when he ran into that brother
like man engineering can't take down
that brick house
no sir okay so queen b3 hitting a4
hitting the bishop queen takes a force
threatens queen episode
munching it's just it's wrong
well if it's wrong icard doesn't want to
be right oh you are you are saying it
true sir oh my gosh he's gonna take on
a1 he's my rook c1 check to trade
everything off
oh well
six wins out of the gate for the number
one seed and defending champion hickory
nakamura
maybe he watched enough of the magnus
match and he was like enough is enough
here i come um
this is shocking i'm shocked i'm legit
shocked and it's
not that we don't know hikaru's capable
of this but we also know how great fedo
save is and you remember what fedo said
did to ferugia
who uh let me remind you never led in
that match right trailed the whole way
that's how dominant fiddle save was
even though it went to overtime even
there he never quite let his guard down
but here
he is running up against the train of
nakamura
just i don't even know what to say uh
this is
beyond impressive and for fedo say of
they've had recent blitz matches of
probably around 20 games where federal
save actually came out on top so
it is possible for fedocere to take down
hikaru as strong as zekaro is
and while hikara knows that he came well
prepared
he's playing these positions that sort
of minimize the risk
for himself and i i have noticed that i
mean look at this opening here
black's piece is pretty cramped even if
black is able to stabilize
and ensure that he's not so much worse
is he really ever going to be
better and the answer doesn't really
look like yes
yeah i mean i talk about i feel like
every time you and i are here i tend to
take the defensive position of the
structure and say yeah but it's solid
and yeah but you can liberate your
pieces eventually but hikaru
knows these systems so well i feel like
at this point
i've been seeing enough of hikaru on the
white side of this that
you know if i was an ambitious chess
player i'd review the games and take
more notes because
i know this is blitz chess but these are
you know the most money we've ever had
on the line the evolution of online
chess has been very real over the last
few years and we know these
these games make it into chess space
right twick gathers them and these guys
these games are studied and these guys
often don't hold back their
prep so yeah i mean hicaro just kind of
knows what he's doing here and he's
always well prepared on the white side
of the qgd
he is although fedor sayev in game one
he was able to neutralize hikaru for
quite a while
and he played bishop b7 rook c8 rook c7
kind of doubled up his rooks in the c
file and eventually broke with the move
c5
i would say a difference in this game
compared to that is that black's pawn is
on a5
which means that if you ever play c5 for
black the b5 square is
permanently whites for the taking so
that's an important note that
if you have pawns two squares away from
one another the square between
is often for your opponent and you're
just
seeing control of it yeah you said it
well even though black's mission is
solid it's also passive and so it's like
the dreams are bishop b7 and get the
rook over right and and then what right
and why is debating
uh between the same themes you
highlighted when we first had this
opening
do i go for e4 and try to flex with the
pawns in space or do i leave that square
open for
for flexible ideas like knight e4 that
that opened the c file
i will say one thing in fedo say of
defense a5 prevents icaru's idea
remember from that game where bishop a6
was played
to eliminate this bishop and attack the
weak pawn so notice
notice that cardo changes gears and goes
for this idea instead
and i would immediately play bishop f4
for black uh
there's some risk of a move like that
because the bishop just attacks the rook
oh let's go to the analysis board
analyze because i think my partner was
right on that
right on the money i think black had to
play the move bishop f4
right when it was played the computer
agrees with you man
the rook moves and now you can strive
for your c5 moves
the rook is on the queen is there even
ah there's no nice c5 stuff
and the best part about it is just that
your bishop isn't getting caught behind
the pawns
so i don't know if it's actually that
good i'm you know worried that
the bishop gets some trouble but i don't
like the current game position
where the bishop is now yeah
sorry i was just analyzing before
it was a great move but you like you
said the current game situation with
bishop b7 you notice how quickly hiccaro
played e5
he didn't have to be asked twice to
block off that move
that probably fedo said should have
played and now hikaru is
taking advantage of the b5 square as you
prophesized
this is no fun and also the bishop on c7
look at it it's staring to e5 which is
defended for the time being
uh end
right it's it's pinned it's weak um
you can take on c5 if you want to ruin
black's pawn structure on that side of
the board
it's just not a fun position for fedo
sev
and we've said that before unfortunately
for him
and this is one of those things where
now it's like the momentum right i mean
we know how good fredo seave is but the
momentum here it's like now he's
now you start fighting your own head
right because you've lost six in a row
right and i'm going to add another
chest point here that i keep talking
about bishop versus knight dynamic
if black is stuck with this bishop on b8
good luck to your light squares on the
queen side and i think that's part of
the reason why photos have just went
bishop a6
saying hey i'm going to challenge your
knight and maybe capture it at some
moment
so that your knight can't just dominate
my bishop on b8 and he does just this
the compromise um or the concession if
you will of doing such is that you give
away the light squares permanently so
now hicaro has
a new square for business will he try to
use the knight tactically
there's the e5 pawn and the and the h4
pawn to worry about
but even if you don't go that way
although actually the more i look at it
look how awkward this is the queen is
trying to guard maybe too many things
just for example if you take
black can even maybe take here and then
take here
and e5 falls in the end and h4 falls so
actually hikaru xc8 whoa look at that
he was laughing in the face of the queen
for good reason
right and not the first time today that
he's been willing to give up screening
for some rooks
and danny you could take h4 you could
take e5
have fun with those pawns the knight
comes into c6 and
b6 is also a problem you wish that pawn
can go back to a7 for black
so that b6 isn't hanging and it's just a
nice square for the knight even if the
pawn were not hanging but it is
on b6 and this is just problematic
i mean it just i seriously
feel for vladimir because
i know what it's like to feel like i
didn't do anything wrong
i'm just playing the normal stuff but
then you start not you don't trust
yourself anymore you're like i've lost
all these games i need to change
something up
i need to play a different opening i
need to play more aggressively because
my strategic more passive play isn't
working out but my tactical play is not
working out either
hikaru nakamura is just a card nakamura
at the end of the day
i don't even know why that's bad but oh
wait g3 running out of squares
uh-huh queen's running i i just had a
feeling
you know what happens when i get that
feeling it's a chess you will feel
well 97 check is winning a rook so i
hope you enjoyed it wow the queen cannot
touch these squares
and so she runs to that side of the
board 97 picks up the rook for free
omg and or snaps
if you got the emote use it omg's are
snaps is what i just said
we've had a lot of subscribers today
thank you for the support i'm going to
go ahead and use my
omg's or snaps unless you want me to
hescasm are you in the mood for a hess
gasmess
it's probably the most inappropriate and
weirdest thing you could ask me
uh on stream but you know
i guess if there's a time for it a car
being up seven to nothing maybe that's
the time
okay we'll just do we'll do omgs or
snaps instead
there we go dark side beat me to it
um there it is just come on jesus snaps
at least you know how to get the chat
riled up daddy yeah we got 28
000 of them on twitch 8 500 on youtube
this is the most viewers we've had all
day
um and uh we think thank you for being
here um
oh the italian right back
in all italian but this is not quite the
italian we saw yesterday because
uh unlike those games ferocious was able
to push his pawn to b4
because a5 was played only after b4 was
played so
a bit of a different setup we did see
hikaru play
one really nice game when white
overextended and then he was playing on
both sides of the board
but i think this is a good choice by
vladimir considering the score
considering his mindset
i i feel like his position for now is
quite solid
okay yeah it's flexible right good
choice maybe give cecaro ideas of
overextending if you're not careful with
the lawn chain
um the car taking his time here
getting a little bit down on the clock
he looks troubled what face is this
what what face was that what a car sorry
i was actually looking at the chest and
not hikaru i'm sorry i missed oh there
we wait hold on
that's not number 19 nor number seven
what is that dude give it to me again
buddy
come on in carl throw me the face
it was an open mouth gate it's very it's
very rare
in a wild hikaru his own
natural habitat where you get to add a
new face to the catalog
so what number is that now i don't know
i don't know i didn't see it long enough
okay
world's leading expert means i also have
to humbly admit when i don't know what
i'm talking about okay even if i do know
his faces very well
um i do like this transition he's trying
to force the iqp
or this pawn will be a target um
white has the ideas of 949c5 though yeah
that'll save playing well if he can
find a way to make something of this
italian he's got an advantage maybe for
the first time today
yeah 94 is a good move because uh if
black
does not take on d5 perhaps white will
be able to keep that extra pawn this
isn't really a very good pawn
but if you're not winning it back i'll
gladly keep that one
and your 94 also can go to c5 in the
future that was
my idea let's analyze it real quick and
uh
see what see what he's thinking about
why not knight e4
i like it you like it if it takes we
have two ideas robert nice c5 but you
can also play the
knight to e5 right and there's just this
like
you know this x-ray vision you're
worried about on f7
as we said the knight is also coming to
c5
95 played immediately similar ideas i
expect 94 to come here soon and indeed
it does
yeah you said x-ray vision i'm just
worried about my regular vision so i
don't know
hope we can get that behind us if you
know what i mean hindsight let's hope
it's 20 20 soon
knight c5 well perfect prediction danny
you you had this all
mapped out in hikara's face that is not
a happy hikaru
yeah he's uh wishes he could make like
taylor swift and shake this one off but
i think fedor says says i'm not getting
adopted today buddy
all right no knight takes e6 i would
take that bishop
and then go after the light squares we
just
saw hikaru use the light squares in a
previous game right
going for checkmates on the king side
here the e6 pawn the g6 square
if that bishop can go from c4 to uh
a2 g8 diagonal to go to the b1 h7
diagonal
there may be some mating opportunities
as well yep
27 kind of forced to defend e6 but
there's there's still bishop a3 with
tempo and knight c5 there's also
maybe simple moves right kind of sit
tight on the position sometimes i like
moves like g3 to hold f4 and just like
queen e2 bring the rook over
white is white is definitely better also
up on the clock
for the sake of mercy you have to root
for fedo save in this game
bishop c5 just run out i like it bring
that piece in
the bishop on b2 wasn't doing anything
so at least on c5 it offers the trade
while keeping before safe and sound
and i by the way i did like your idea
with g3 not now
probably but g3 was a good move just to
give the kid oh my gosh rookie two i
like that
yeah that's a move to make the battery
work for you
put the rook in front of the queen where
the battery is often most effective
i really like that um wait a second
there's got to be some kind of tactics
here
i got e5 i've got b6 where's the beef
a5 is also hanging in some of these
lines also at target
maybe it's as simple as that robert
capture once you have to take this way
because of the pin
capture b6 and win a5 with tempo in fact
i might have just called the combo
indeed here we go there it is
so an extra pawn a french-like pawn
structure for black with this e6 pawn
being a weakness
and plenty of time for fredo save this
has been a good game by him and
really the first one so far that we've
seen you know 30 moves deep
where he can claim that he has an
advantage
yeah no seriously uh he's played very
well in this game start to finish
and if you're a federal save fan you're
like go back to this go back to this
opening go back to this approach
been very clean now we're assuming he
converts
we know that hikaru like magnus is very
good at persevering and defending bad
positions so
i'm not claiming victory for white just
yet that's all
i just black doesn't really have any
ideas which is the sad part
knight f4 is a big threat and that's why
g3 gives the king space so there's no
background checkmates to worry about
but also gives the knight this important
f4 square
to attack e6 and win the e6 pawn
directly so
i think that hikaru might have to try
knight d6 to put them then
e4 blocking the file but
then it can only last for so long
eventually
white just taken over there yeah moving
the knight allows the e5 square to
be open for business so has his
defensive work cut out for him we'll see
if he can hold
an aggressive move attacking the knight
asking if it'll save what he intends to
do with it
i think you'd like the major piece end
game if 95 hikaru might
might trade bring the queen in to maybe
e3 or c2 or something
and we'll see because the problem is e6
also hangs but my point is do we think
the major piece end game improves to
carl's drawing chances i guess he does
he might have felt like he has no choice
i think that he's feeling like he's he
hates his position you saw that face i
don't know what number it is but
and here comes f5 now that's a truly
frustrated nod not the uh the confident
not that's a hikaru nakamura number five
not to be confused with the mambo number
five i knew you're gonna say
exactly that i thought about beating you
to the punch and i was like nope
can't say it couldn't bring it i'm gonna
let him do it
i'll give you a chance to complete my
later your sandwiches
rook c8 now look at this plain tickle on
both sides of the board is where it's at
that's what the cool kids do now
h4h5 oh i wanted it on h4h5 keep the
brooks on the board bro
he's not going to keep the rooks in the
board because the rookless position he
will try to give himself this outside
pass pawn on the queen side he is up one
but h4 now
is a good move i think actually you can
still go h4 h5
okay actually didn't go anywhere
h4 h5
are you saying i guess the problem is if
h4 you maybe run into h5 right so that's
probably what he's thinking about
i don't actually maybe want him to
blockade that way
but i'll say i'm gonna take a second
play slow oh queens
look at that move forces the c file to
be owned by black
uh we may have spoken too soon about
start to finish for fedocere because
yeah this doesn't look so easy
i think a car will play h5 and indeed he
does he's just going to try to hold
there's a candy cart yeah i was going to
say queen c1 yeah
just bringing the queen in what no i was
going to say just bring the queen in and
i could actually see
a world where black wins this game if
white tries crazy to say that you shush
your mouth when you're talking to me
don't you don't you say that don't you
should say that by the way only 40
seconds left
let's remind you that at the break we
will have another prime time smackdown
for all of our subscribers the rest of
you will enjoy the sweet sounds of a
commercial for a product you're never
going to buy
but subscribe now throw us your prime uh
i don't even know who it is we're gonna
find out i think it's danny wrench
versus daniel daraditsky
let's just say that spoilers and upsets
happen
um do you just refer to yourself
by your name without saying you know i
played it's been a long day
oh no did you just say you saw a world
where black wins this game
i told you to shut your mouth
i'm laughing at you not at anything else
you okay over there danny oh wow
queenie one check queen takes a5 coming
with
tempo and black is going to win this
game
you know what lesson learned i'm going
to shush my mouth when i speak you are
going to shush your mouth when you're
talking to me
[Laughter]
oh man poor plato mirror and you see a
car shaking his head he doesn't feel
good about it either okay
he doesn't feel good about it either um
wow seriously yeah no i mean the thing
about
d7 matches especially when
um you know people are enjoying
themselves you know
in the chat i think hikaru has
you know we're saying he's a lot of
respect for fidosev obviously and he
kind of knows
right that he didn't deserve this game
from he didn't play his best chess let's
put that right
but he also knows that what happens when
you start
winning all your games if somebody
doesn't get a win people in the chat
start talking
and i think he feels for fedo say
because he knows how
good of a player vladimir no it's
totally true
and it's the same reason why you know
magnus kind of laughed and
you know shook his head when he won some
games against artemia that you know
shocked the world
hashtag knight versus queen we should
have started a hashtag knight vs queen
um i assume you saw that game yeah but
it'd be like the least successful
hashtag of all time
okay well i've started a few of those
of the least successful hashtags ever
look at this
white might even get mated
yeah i'm not doing this anymore
no i'm kidding but seriously this is
jokes aside
don't let the results fool you fedo save
is an absolute freak
and uh this is this is shocking again
hicaro clearly wanted to
send a message make a statement bring
his a game insert
overblown sports cliche robber but what
can you say about 8-0 after five minutes
we've never seen this have we
you know i could say it's a chess match
out there i mean
if both coaches think it's several steps
ahead sometimes it feels like there's a
stalemate between the players
but then oh they overcome the odds and
win but in all seriousness danny hikaru
nakamura
is playing one of the finest matches
i've ever seen and this is a guy who
went toe-to-toe
with magnus carlson all this pandemic
and he is just came out of the gates
really just in fine form
precise chess never giving fedor say of
positions he was quite comfortable with
until this game and this is just the
type of day it is for a car that even
in his worst it's still right now out
playing
fetuses best and it's just a big issue
for vlad hill will win some games going
forward
but hikaru nakamura should be very proud
of the match he's played thus far
well said nothing more to add thank you
to our subscribers enjoy this prime time
smackdown at the break
and robert hess and i will be right back
with the 3-1 segment in today's speed
chess championship match
[Music]
dania how do you get your hair to stay
so curly i mean how many times you get a
perma day you're not going to talk
how many times only once actually i
don't use anything any special condition
or nothing
really uh nothing no it's just it's just
the way that i am and i'll deal even my
hair will be look even better when i'm
finished thrashing you
whatever i didn't even wear my chest.com
shirt for you today but i did almost put
my western invitational chest camp shirt
on which is funny
i went with vulcan but i see you wearing
the chess camp shirt that you and i
taught at together
the last time i was holding you while
you were crying after having way too
many of these
remember that way too many uh you were
holding me
i see i remembered it a little bit
differently no
no okay but in uh
in life like chess your big brother's
always here for you
when i give you a spanking that shocks
the world okay
actually i don't know just in a nice
place here we go you've given me
exactly one spanking and i'll give you
that at the world open thousand
nine and i mentioned you could do this
dating don't hyperventilate
man this is a very good game danny all
right let's get this party under so yeah
you did that once okay i give you that
never again
i have the experience of losing to danny
wrench once that was the first and the
last time
that's what they all say oh yeah that's
what they all say they all say that they
all say it
e5 that was a great move man where did
you learn this theory
i i need to put pick that book up danny
wrench's guide to the opening
i know you're being sarcastic and i
don't appreciate it dude i'm never
sarcastic what are you talking about man
i'm always really nice to you danny yeah
give me a point i am worse here i
i apprecia i accept that but i play word
i play better and now in worse position
so that was all deliberate
yeah all part of the campaign you and
bartholomew have a lot of cloning like
that
oh yeah i try to hang out with the cool
people when i teach in arizona
all right fine we'll go into the end
game i'm crushing you i'm playing so
well right now i'm so proud
all right it's time to get serious
though no you are actually playing
pretty well
but i'm just waiting for that to end i
just want to be around here there's the
blunder
there's the blunder
wait am i up with these oh
daniel
oh wait a minute i didn't you believe me
for a second
oh crap how did i not get a queen out of
that that was hardly even fair
should have played the queen's gambit oh
jesus that was
so awkward and so good i love you that
was amazing man
hey why don't you promote i'm gonna
check
i get zero points for that for the
thrashing of like the greatest bullet
player in the world
ah the greatest bullet player in the
world
will someone clip that um he just said
that
and uh with this kind of performance you
wonder how hikaru nakamura
might do against himself ikarubot on
chess.com because
he's playing like a machine right now an
absolute accurate freak
and just uh putting on a show and uh
we'll see
everyone tomorrow on december 4th for
the bot battles i'll be streaming on my
own channel
we'll have commentary on the main
channel as well along with dozens of
other streamers
i believe we have almost 100 streamers
ready to play with tons of cash prizes
going to be a blast
robert what can we say about this 8-0
performance which i believe is the first
time in history
someone has been blanked in the 5-0
portion
there's not really much that can be said
hikaru nakamura plays
one of the best segments of chess you've
ever seen
from him he was lights out from start to
finish he just was getting the types of
positions that he thrives in
as early as game two i was saying how i
loved his decision making he went for a
tactical position
that he saw through better than feather
save did and for fedo say
it's really hard when you start losing
one game the second game
you're in your own mindset like i i know
hikar is the favorite
everybody knows that but i can do this
and then
trying to encourage yourself becomes
increasingly difficult
the more games that you lose uh you said
it well and now the question is what
can he do in the 3-1 segment right it's
a faster time control a new day so if
you were in
fedor saves corner you know at this
point you're not even thinking about a
comeback right you're thinking about
like the next game
right quite literally just focus on the
next game
one move at a time get yourself on the
scoreboard and figure out
you know the probability that you could
ever come back later right that's not
even your problem at this point
and it sounds silly but when it comes to
competitors that's why you hear coaches
and sports talk talk about that all the
time because sometimes
all you can do is focus on what you can
control not the scoreboard
and that would be exactly what fedo said
should do right now is focus on the next
game
which we'll be starting in just seconds
we will have liftoff here and uh
right on cue there we go
you know how you ask if you're
somebody's coach what do you tell them
frankly i don't know what i would have
told vladimir
in that break and that's just to say
that
he's not playing poorly there were a
couple games where he just
did some things that he knows were not
good and it's because he's frustrated
but for the most part he's been playing
quite well it just feels like in some
critical moments hikaru is getting the
upper hand and
at a certain point you just have to
acknowledge that the opponent you're
facing
is that good and at his best you're not
going to be able to match him it's kind
of what you're saying going forward here
right just try to get a couple points
stop the bleeding i don't think that
this opening
is necessarily a good choice to stop it
but you took the words out of my mouth i
was just about to say
this is the this is the road to adoption
and i hate to use that word i said i
wouldn't use it i called out shaft for
saying it
but now you're down 8-0 and this is a
tilt opening and the main reason we said
everyone is you're you know it's
big center and all kinds of ways to make
it work tactically there's already ideas
with e6 being punched through
uh the knights are coming into these
squares over here with the bishop
it's this is it's not your main opening
and it's not an opening you should play
when you're on tilt as hard as that is
to say right we've been in
fedo say of shoes easier said than done
but i'm not a fan of the approach
no certainly not either and one of the
major issues here
is black will regain this pawn c5 but
white can play
bishop e3 make sure that black doesn't
get this d4 move in because the bishop
on b7
is actually not a very good piece and
yes it reminds us of a french
i i always make fun of the french but
this actually is quite like a french
and even worse than a french your knight
is on h6 so unless that knight can
somehow
find its way back towards the middle of
the board it's a piece that's not
helping you out and white can also
consider the move a5 here in addition to
bishop e3
cementing the pawn structure on the
queen side and leaving the opponent b4
out in the wild
all the things you said are true and i'm
sitting here wondering whether f5 is
about to be punched in
and i wondered if f5 could have been
played before
that is the danny way to play the
position right back sack and lose by
checkmate to your opponent
um but you know but i think f5 is coming
no g
he's not going he's playing super
positional here which has its merit
based on the long-term negative effects
of the bishop but
i'm gonna say in a rare case i think i
was right about that one i feel like f5
was possible before
black fix things because now the c file
and the light squares
are not as bad as they were you see the
eval bar has gone much closer to equal
as well
yeah i think that the position from an
objective standpoint
with the evaluation bar you don't have
the moves going on for us
it probably says that it should be okay
for black but again let me ask you danny
three moves go three moves go can i
improve my position
no but i can make it worse
no it's true like again we say that a
lot of everyone when we do the
three-move exercise this is coaching
advice from danny and robert it's not
that you imagine oh if i had three moves
i'd take
take and take right well obviously you
would everybody would okay that's not
the exercise the exercise is
three usually non-capture moves what
would you do
it's like you say things like rook b8
bishop c4
and i can't make a move that improves it
right you say like f6
to change the pawn structure but i can't
do that so the point robert's making is
how do you fix the position with even
like your best three moves robert would
be like knight g8 97 and rook b8 those
are that's my answer
right and i think you'd probably agree
but the problem is even that means black
is just still clearly worse
right and those actually are a very good
suggestion maybe that's what you need to
do
but that's why hikaru played c3 was to
open up the position in favor of ways
for him and the a5 pawn now
becomes a target and if brook takes c8
queen takes a 5 certainly
can be played you'll snag that pawn and
it's good for white so
and bishop takes black's pieces are
going backwards this knight on d4
is such an amazing piece it blockades
blocks
past pawn and you shouldn't think of
this position as being even material
how you should think of it is well yes
we have the same number of pieces but
white has a two on one majority on the
queen side
and black has an extra pawn from the d
through the h file white has control
over the c file
black's pieces are more passive the
knight on g8 f8 bishop on c8
rook on eight your pieces are all in the
last rank white's pieces are a bit more
active so
everything in this position seems to
favor white and that's why danny and i
are saying that white's position is just
clearly favorable
yeah and again the battery created here
really nice threatens rook
c7 and even rook c8 is not a move you
can play i think because he can just
trade everything and put a knight on c6
yeah and the pawn on a5 is going to fall
man as you said this night here
not quite a horse more than a horse of
course it's a unicorn a rare shout out
to chess tv emotes rarely does chess tv
get to use emotes that twitch doesn't
have let me find it
where's the unicorn where's the unicorn
i've already told you this danny but you
should watch the show the unicorn
i don't even know what you're talking
about but i just i feel like you'd be
you'd be a walton goggins fan
just by his sense of humor i'm serious
unicorn
you're not gonna that you know i missed
the reference say it again i'm sorry i
don't like to
you should watch the show the unicorn i
think you'd enjoy it
really yeah this is this legitimate
you know friend to friend hey we can do
this later you know
we're not commenting dress but i'm just
letting you know that i think you'd
enjoy it
i appreciate that no seriously um you
know i've been looking for a new show to
watch when i have any time
the best person i met this year was ted
lasso right
love that guy oh boy um you
you know you're a very busy guy we know
all right queen d6 oh my god that's a
that's an annoying move cutting off the
communication of the defense of the
knight
you can't trade because the d-pawn will
run
and now he's just gonna play knight c6
and
no no that would lose the knight yeah
but he'll take on b4 and then use the a
pawn
now the a pawn is running nice little
passer
what's stopping you from just using the
a pawn here
he didn't push the last move maybe he
could have did you see his reaction he
was mad at himself yeah why didn't i do
that why didn't i play a5 no i mean now
you let the king catch it
like yeah
that's that's icaro's least favorite
face number 21. i agree with danny
he hates that one but seven there's d4
yeah and actually fiddle save is barely
holding on wait now you can
oh what oh my gosh fetter save got one
and look oh my god that was a blunder by
hikaru
yeah okay we could have a turnaround
the adoption may not happen it happens
in in
an awkward fashion the first time we've
seen hikaro blunder all day
for sure and actually the evaluation bar
it swung heavily
in fedocero's favor but now it's back to
level so there clearly was a moment
there missed by fedo sayo yeah
i wonder what it was i'll have to we'll
let the game finish and we'll bring up
the analysis board at the start of the
next one because i'm sure it's
instructive where black had the wind
is he just going to take the draw yeah i
think so you might
know he's like like so bad
that it does sound like a car i'm so
it's what he just said i read his lips
he said so i'm so bad
because oh man oh man is the adoption
back on
oh no oh no oh no
no vladimir
you know what's funny though danny is
that immediately car went right back
into wait there's so much more chest to
be played right that that
god and he goes fully focused and he's
only got five seconds this is
so hard to hold so knight east
knight d6 no you play 96 first because
knight takes e6
guards c7 and then you have a queen
yeah oh my gosh king c6 okay knight d4
also looks good
pawn in the game would be winning
so 11 seconds a car has time to figure
this one out he pushes the pawn through
now he'll go to f5 i think and does the
knight cap
catch the pawn if he oh my gosh no moves
are black he's using zug's one because
the knight is frozen
no he's not stalemating he gets it with
check oh my gosh
on freaking believable hikaru's like i
don't know what to tell you
like oh my gosh
okay back to the analysis board what
just happened first of all i want to
figure out
where was fedo say of winning right
it was it was here
before this whole deep uh night knight
takes should have taken with the king i
guess
now i think knight takes was fine but
judging by the fact that king d5 was the
wrong move he probably
brought knight to c3 first that's my
guess ah knight to c3 to offer the trade
first
okay this makes a big difference and if
the knight goes to f6
you can maybe go even to d5 and offer
the trade again your knight kind of
works around to maybe hit this pawn
well f4 was hanging there too okay so
knight d5 is a real problem
yep wow okay
so he doesn't do that
ping d5 is a huge mistake and somehow
the hikaru gets the perpetual that by
the way
i don't say it wasn't happy at a certain
point though which is what we criticized
the opening being itself
at a certain point shouldn't fedele say
if just take the draw
right just get on the board and stop the
bleeding
so at that point you're kind of doing it
to yourself right with king c6
yeah although you know if he wants to
yeah for fedor save right if we go back
to the live uh
the new game just so we can uh catch up
with everybody
and the board but for fedo save i don't
know if he actually cares
about losing 10 games zero i know the
online sphere makes a big deal of being
adopted this and that right
i've been adopted by a car nakamura no
shame in that i've been adopted by yonda
palmashi
i'm not sure if fedocide actually cares
about all that stuff he wants to win the
match and if he's going to win the match
he needs to start winning games
so he said hey a drawing at this point
is the same as a loss let me just try
something
and hope that i can somehow sneak in a
victory but
i don't disagree but also like you know
how it is when you're like beating
yourself right it's hard to overcome the
psychological
aspects of that and just getting on the
board there's a reason why a lot of
coaches will say
look if you've lost two in a row in a
closed event you play like a forcing
line in the net i mean you try to like
psychologically get a point
that is not a a zero right and it's
advice that a lot of people give just
for those
human psychology reason so i i agree
with you and obviously a draw
doesn't change that we would have said
you know hikaru nakamura is on his way
to winning the match
just i just feel like because here's the
thing dude
was king c6 really creating winning
chances like
zero right like it was it wasn't like a
dynamic affair
where we're like complimenting the
dragon right
you know it was just one of those
positions where
uh that's all your heart goes out to him
yeah and i see the chats all riled up
about the adoption
and all this and that uh just you know i
i think the point that i'm making
is true i really don't think that
vladimir losing eight games in a row is
just as painful for him as losing nine
or ten
the number is still going to bother him
at the end of the day
but uh you know i do hope that chat has
fun that's what we're here for a good
time
it is a thing that people report and
frankly it is a thing that nobody would
have said coming into this match right
so
we do have to say that but but again and
and you know what robert's saying is
true about federal sales mindset i just
think that at a certain point
you take a draw there because because
playing for
uh anything else was literally playing
for a loss there there were no other
chances although i will say this he did
have the idea of the knight coming
around maybe he overestimated the whole
uh you know the way the knight
remaneuvered to e2 and
and with the h4 move but all right
enough is enough we're on to the next
minute game hikaru is in a dominant
position
yep you're in the board over there i'm
on a dominant board
spot um i wonder if i can fix this
chrome feature that
makes the never mind um the bishop is
better than the knight with the pawns on
both sides of the board that was the
thing i was going to highlight in the
dominant position
also there are no pawns to uh attack
with this light square bishop so even
though black is up two pawns
you have these double isolated c pawns
in apon
that's isolated as well so actually
creating a password from here is not so
easy
but knight takes d5 it's a critical
question for vladimir
can he take this bishop and then run his
king in first
i'm guessing the answer is no and the
answer must be no but it is an awkward
king upon ending that you would ever
even be questioning
that you could go into down a pawn but
it's that tricky
right and black can give up c7 and bring
the king to f5 and run the kingdom
calculating all this i'm watching him
calculate
he's doing the finger pointing
calculations doing the finger
is his point yeah the h pawn is faster
it's faster than the b-pawn yeah so so
i mean we're going to see it all happen
i don't even need to say anything right
here comes
no it's not
i don't think it is
fedo sam's calculation is accurate
checks out
we're both going to get queens
white's going to get f5 check at the end
only hicaro can win the game but will
federal save draw and hold off
adoption he snuck in f5 first that was
really smart oh what a
sweet move that was no no he's not going
to win
no okay sorry i i for a second i thought
he was queening with chuck with the pawn
still on h2 but no it's still a draw
but that is so instructive and the
reason why i mean we
would have to bring up an analysis board
to yeah we're going to as soon as the
results in and we officially escape the
10 and a result
um hicary was going to laugh it off for
a second well let's go to the analysis
board now to the batcave
let robert instruct on why f5 was such a
crucial idea
before um sorry i'm going
going back uh
but wait i mean the last game yeah
you're in the wrong game i'm sorry i
switched games
five right here um so instead of playing
f5 let's say we
uh right instead of pausing b5 just yeah
just promote for both sides
right and you see the evaluation go and
the reason why
is that after queening f5 check for
white
king g4 queen a1 check is important
exactly what's so funny is that
if i had to guess dude okay the game
ends in a draw we do not have adoption
i'm going to keep analyzing this as the
next one begins
if i had to guess knowing how well we
know hikaru and what he's capable of
if i had to guess when hikaro was
calculating king f5
he saw this idea of checking on a1
and trading queens and that he would win
the end game and what he
missed was the move order of f5 first
and i believe that explains partly his
reaction of laughing is that it wasn't
b4
and just upon race was that fedo say
have actually found the right move order
and played the move f5 before b5
making the queen with check and
literally saving adoption in the process
carl also was pre-moving by the way not
that it would have made a difference but
i think he was pre-moving at that point
so he might not have been expecting f5
at that moment or he probably seen it at
this point but still
it just came at the right time for
fedocef
yeah a really instructive idea shows you
that move orders matter and again just
to highlight robert's point
if you go for this that was such an
instructive thing that i think probably
hicaro had calculated
just to show the key point is again in
this line now you lose never forget
when you analyze end games everyone
don't stop in your head where both sides
get a queen
you always have to go to the first sides
delivering their checks
and seeing what they're capable of are
they capable of some sort of tactic
that either wins the queen or trades
queens we see a lot of end games lost at
the low levels where people stop their
calculation at the queen
instead of all the way to the end right
right and
it's good just try to calculate that one
step more
very difficult to do uh fedor sayev he
managed to make it work he's not making
this position work though i'm gonna be
honest with you danny he's down a clean
pawn
he's knights are all sorts of awkward on
a6 and c7
and look at hicara's knight jumping
right into the juicy d6 square
so another one i think kikaro is taking
here
well it would not be 10 in a row those
rooting for it
did not get what they wanted i for one
was not rooting for it because
you know mercy that's why
um and uh but yeah hikaru is right back
at it looks like he's gonna get another
victory here
he won a clean pawn and now he's
dominating
the middle of the board to go along with
it
for sure the 1986 particularly useless
over there
it's uh can't move it's not only good
square to begin with
and white up a pawn
can pick from many different good moves
i would say
uh rook d2 looks good g3 of course
protects f4 uh with a pawn i
i don't say danny i don't have too many
words here
yeah it's a super tough position um
someone in chat just said why is
vladimir not playing his normal openings
and i
you know i don't disagree that you know
it's one of the reasons we criticized
that game
um you shouldn't have lost in the end
but the game he ultimately lost
uh as black that was number nine you
know it's hard sometimes when
when you're when you're in a position
like this
it's very difficult to get a hold of
yourself and
even for the best players the tilt can
be real and in this case we we're seeing
exactly what it can what it can do to
someone when
we know hikaru is not you know normally
going to win a match against fedo say of
like this
but at the same time you know he's a
beast and this is what he's capable of
if he gets on a roll and
fedo save is having a trouble a lot of
trouble gathering himself
yeah and with the prize fund the way it
is danny
right where you the winner gets i think
three thousand dollars
in this round and then the remaining
three thousand dollars is split by win
percentage
yep i think fetishes winning not a lot
of money right now
as of this moment he's won 200
or maybe not even maybe 150 for the draw
um
the point is every result is important
for him well it also is a point why he
should continue to fight and come back
right i mean he doesn't want to waste a
three and a half four hour effort with
you know going home with a with a
handshake and a couple bucks he'd like
to
like to get you know into the four
figures get a thousand bucks even if
ricardo takes five
um and if we're being serious i mean yes
of course these players uh you know
they appreciate the generous prize fund
offered but
i think ultimately what federer said
wants to do is just win some games
because he know he can and
chess right now he's focusing less on
his wallet and more on
how can i play my best chess because i
know that i can
take some games from hikar nakamura
for sure
so this position actually looks nice for
white you have the bishop pair yeah
we saw the way the other italian yeah
sorry go ahead no i was about to say the
same thing
we saw him working a position similar to
this
he ended up getting an isolated pawn and
played well in that one
before things went south but here it
looks
like weiss pieces are in perfect
position but danny on the flip side
where's the real weakness for black
everything seems pretty solid for the
time being
yeah it's hard because all the tension
surrounds this right you
you know those positions you tell
beginners you get to make all your moves
in the opening centralize your brooks
develop your bishops this is like almost
one of those dream positions
but now what do you do with it ikaru has
over defended the e5 pawn
it's actually a very good question like
okay he played bishop d3
interesting he's defending e4 the pawn
was attacked three times if you think
about e takes d4 on the consequence
so he felt the need to protect he plays
g3 pawn three squares away from knight
dominates that knight so the knight on
g6 loses its
forward progress can't get to f4 now and
i i like white's position but look at
hikaru's move came to h e
he's saying do something how are you
going to
improve on an aesthetically pleasing
position into an actual advantage
so he just says king king she's gonna
play king j8 now
okay but he put knight five my bad he
went for a little more knight of four
being a threat
i guess
you good there you go you're like super
focused like trying to figure out super
focused on the chess section
um and i'm not super thrilled
with where the position is headed for
fedo save our defending uh
slightly worse position in the italian
yet again and now it's
unclear although you know you do still
like white's chances if you get the
couple pawns up and the bishop pair
are still capable of monstrous things on
the diagonals but
this is better than it was earlier for
black
yeah you actually have some active
counter play you're staring at this pawn
e4 your bishop on b6 has new life on the
diagonal
you know f4 is an obvious idea and it
was just played
for white but that creates some
weaknesses of its own right the e4 pawn
can no longer be defended with a pawn
because you can't go f2 to f3 the pawns
push too far and g3
becomes a bit loose look for sacrifices
on that square at some point
of course don't hang your queen bishop
g1 check is a threat now
but you said it white white should be
better it just doesn't feel very easy to
prove
yeah now right back at you there's
discoveries here on this queen not
quite bishop g1 but it'll say okay yeah
bishop c4
you open up the attack interesting the
trade happens i think white just wins a
pawn in the end
i'm looking for some kind of knight
takes that for sacrifice probably
doesn't quite work out so i i don't know
if you can get away with it
but it's scary it's scary all right
and you can also take on e2 and take
that pawn in c3 to restore the
material i guess so but f7 falls in the
end along with this so does the knight
well g3 is hanging first ah duh okay
yeah queen and knight double attack over
here good point
full board awareness dan
um so that's actually a huge point
i don't say if probably takes h5 first
there's no mating net on the dark
squares i don't think bishop can always
come back
yeah so rook d3
now i i guess queen a1
hmm so my queen d3 is
sort of forced i'm not really
seeing much more than that i don't
particularly want to offer a queen trade
i would like to
keep my queen with the bishops
dominating but he plays rook d3
ah we're prop
yep that'll save us razor focus he wants
that first victory
he does not want to botch this one look
at the position he's got the two big
ships
a couple of bishops and well-placed
want to get this game if you're fed us
say of you know even if the computer
says it's close to equal from a
practical point of view this is
much easier to be white and one of the
big reasons why is and
icar did not play rook d8 which would
have encouraged in exchange of rooks
is that the white king has much easier
access to the queen side it was on king
g2 and then just
darted whereas the king on g8 is cut off
because the bishops
can operate on both sides of the board
so all right
hikaru now oh he does he offers the rook
trade but
but i'm with you this now here comes the
threat of bishop to b6
probably knight f6 is in order but after
the bishop moves
or even to c6 you kind of dominate the
knight actually i love that
if knight f6 bishop c6 and you hold all
the entry points
and good luck to your king you're on g
yeah the king's stuck
right you see the kind of games fiddle
save is also very good at i was
oh i did
he is really good at these but
unfortunately he's just in this shape
today where he dropped
i jinxed him yeah you've been the one
commentator cursing him all day
wow icaru gets the pawn gets back
defends everything if bishop takes f4
was such a sweet tactic
i wouldn't even highlight it because
we're we're so you know just kind of
blown away
blown away right now by nakamura's
performance but the point is if you took
black was forking the king and the
bishop um
this is still going to be a draw but not
a
win for fedor savin what was that move
you might have just put your pawns on
dark squares cecaro doesn't think it's
good either
he's trying to get after this h4 pawn
but
ferris stage is going to put his king
over there and there's no way to team up
on it look at that smile by
hicar there yeah it was like a v for
vendetta face
b for vendetta smile yeah
well i'm still smiling no matter what
we've still got 27 000 on twitch almost
000 on youtube it's been an awesome day
we already had one
speech championship match in the books
magnus carlson took down vladislav
artemyev
and a tale of of two matches we thought
both would be super close
magnus's match with artemyev ultimately
was
this has been a showing by nakamura the
likes of which we've frankly never seen
this is this is as dominant as any scc
match has ever been
um and that's that's that's the best we
can say about it so
thanks for uh everyone being here
yeah they're just playing this one out
there's nothing that
black can do with the opposite colored
bishops you cannot possibly kick the
king off the h3 square and you'll notice
they're just
shuffling their pieces back and forth
who's going to offer the draw first
they're not going to do it now photos
they have smiles
good to see a smile the day that's been
tough
yep and hikaru will play h4 at some
point i feel like
yeah he's gonna say it's gonna be fun
everyone buckle up everyone we're about
to see some fun stuff that'll save
smiles
econo is gonna wait for 50 moves and
play age four
if he does it if it's okay with you
robert i'm gonna get a snack
and i'll be back in five okay sounds
good and he actually i think he was
scrolling through the game to see the
movie
this is awesome although it's not
exactly you know torture he's by the way
he just played h4 right
what he's doing is taking a little bit
of time off the clock uh the match clock
and
at this point
yeah i'm listening
what's your snack gonna be
you put down you're too high
it's too high right now yeah there we go
more down more
down more there we go
bring it close to the cam for everybody
yeah
there it is there's happy icaru
oh if only the players could see what
you're doing right now
[Laughter]
i'm gonna say if only your mom could see
what you're doing she would be frowning
oh so we're move 150 by the way
and look at the car he's just using the
match clock he's just
going to accept the draw for but letting
the clock tick
he looks good in that sweater by the way
again i've said it before
anytime i fed a save or hecaro both
actually
both actually looking good in their
sweaters
this um a lot to talk about in this
position right
danny what do you have for dinner
tonight
great question i don't know um
i brought some salmon in for for uh
lunch after this because it left it we
had we grilled salmon last night you
know
donna makes her awesome it's garlic
ginger soy sauce a little sriracha oh my
god
the best grilled salmon you know you've
had it yeah um
and uh we always make a ton because i
got to bring some to work right so the
kids know you don't eat the last two
pieces of salmon that's dad's
okay bring that into work waiting for me
in the fridge
plus i eat salmon cold you never reheat
fish ever eat it straight up
salmon oh
hey i mean that sounds delicious i grill
the salmon to perfection what you do is
you take the sauce you put on you make a
tin foil bowl
you put the salmon with the skin down
skin goes down you put the salmon on and
then you put the extra ginger and garlic
you rub it on the top
i grill it usually 350 degrees all you
have to do is set for 15 minutes and
walk away it's done
okay you should have a cooking show i
really honestly
i enjoy it so much i would just i should
just turn on the camera more and just
talk everyone through what i'm doing
uh everybody smiled at me
for everybody's sake i think you
shouldn't do that you're on camera
enough danny
how many hours have you been on camera
already today
been it's been a few a few um yeah
by the way what's going on here i don't
say it was better is black
i was listening to your stories aren't
you surprised i paid attention to you
well i'm so i'm so glad um through the
batcave we go
we shall analyze because what happened
in the opening here for us to get here
with fedo say of clearly better as black
king's indian ah the old school de5 with
knight d5 don't see this every day
if you want robert i'm now out of my my
king's indian knowledge with this c6 b5
line
well what i was going to say is these
lines are not supposed to be that
you know great for white it's fine but
doesn't give you your typical advantage
but it could be good in a one-off
blitz game when your opponent's not
super familiar because it's not played
very often
but but federal staff was ready for it
and just to highlight kind of what
robert's talking about as far as the
line this e5 idea is a very typical
approach in the kings indian
and the reason white doesn't just take
twice just so you know the common tactic
is this pawn is not really hanging
due to immediate reversal tactics and
black wins the material with dark square
interest so to speak so if you're not
familiar with that king's indian tactic
at least you learned something today on
the hikaru nakamura
radio network um but hikaru's idea of
knight d5 hits c7 but as robert said
these are not supposed to be great lines
for white
that'll say of doing what he's supposed
to do right just equalizes very quickly
hd5 he's just winning a pawn
right up right this seems healthy to me
yeah and
i mean the way this game is continued
it's well the pawn just actually was
taken
right and black is still better because
the healthier pawn structure you see
that there's
one pawn island for black from the e
file to the h file
and white has isolated b2 pawn well that
pawn might not even exist
in the next couple moves so yeah as you
said the e file the h5 the b2 palm will
probably fall
indeed it will now um
yeah i see chat how much time actually
went off the total game clock during
that
opposite code bishop performance heard
around the world
i wasn't i wasn't keeping track i was
wondering if you had any idea no
no but if you you can do some quick math
i mean how many moves they play 150
moves and then
yeah carl spent the remaining 40 seconds
or so of his clock right
yeah quite a lot of time there several
extra minutes
taken off the clock
so well what are the chances here
they're not as high as it might be with
like
night versus night in some cases am i
right about that because often the
knight is better with the rook on one
side of the board
but they are they are real right i mean
you're up a healthy pawn
your rook is very well placed what what
are the winning chances here for black
compared to a normal like rook and
knight versus rook and knight with four
on three
one of the main issues is that if the
minor pieces get traded
the rook end game is theoretically a
draw not easy to
accomplish even gary kasparov uh has
lost that theoretically dramatically
jerome pickett hashtag
yeah yep i actually met him in tons of
steel
at the beginning of the year and i mean
i talked to him briefly about it it was
cool
to you know meet somebody who beat gary
it's so funny though because he has to
know that he was qui
he's that game is quoted so often as an
example of even the best in the world
are capable of losing things like rook
to b5
fedex is going to get a dub for the
first time today
he just laughed ikaro just laughed that
was a blunder
um
[Music]
even the best in the world do what sorry
i was saying even the best in the world
can lose drawn positions
and i apparently spoke it into existence
because zekaro one of the best in the
world
is about to lose this otherwise drawn
position and
uh but seriously if you don't pick it do
you ask him like hey man what's it like
to be the most quoted player
because you beat gary kasparov in a rook
and four versus freaking three
i'm sure it actually bothers him uh you
can speak to him about that because he's
played better games he just happened to
beat
the biggest name in chess right so right
it's a weird thing whereas
you know he he won a game as obviously
great he was up a pawn he clearly played
well
but it was not his finest game ever
right it wasn't his magnum opus so
uh must right hey guys you know i was
also a grandmaster
2700 plus pretty good at chess for many
years
we end up focusing right on the
individual that you defeated rather than
the game itself and
you know there is obviously some
legitimacy to that but
at the end of the day people do make
mistakes we just saw hikaru drop a
bishop
yeah um you know fenicev hopefully for
his sake and for his fan's sake he can
convert this one i think he should be
able to
but danny what i'm looking at h1 square
dark
color bishop so if the rooks can get
traded and you're left with some h
pawns and that's it that's why he carved
played h5
yeah his car is focused got number 14
rocking
finger in the focus right on the lips
he did anyway he knows this is not as
easy as it looks right because now he's
got that corner pawn
okay it is winning but again there are
there are
endings where even this particular
setup is not a win so you this is this
is really crazy
to think about that but just to
highlight everyone a rook trade is not
possible
because of the wrong color corners so he
caro is not totally unreasonable for
playing this out
and wow um
isn't it funny danny how i'm sure that
you especially are tired
robert why do you always bring up the
bishop and the
you know promoting no i i never get
tired of it seriously i think
you don't have to lie to everybody while
we're alive sometimes you get tired of
it
you like it i really do like it
i like it thank you i appreciate that
this should be five is still made to
rook g5
omgs are snaps if you take either way
and steal me
you sell that so quickly hey there's one
thing i know it's how to lose a winning
position
oh gosh so that um
check and check
second check is the threat putting the
king on the first rank um
watch out the king is stalemated
currently but not anymore
gt okay now now you're getting out but
after rook g8 do not play king h5
so that was right an important little
moment there if you
play you got to play h5 he does
look at the clock by the way federer
down to just three seconds
but i think he's in the right place
because white's king is not in a good
spot to blockade the pawn so easily
so with the rook all the way on f8 so
there's very good chances here
and there's no more stalemate tricks now
this is actually much better for federal
save than the earlier spot because
you don't have that king on that awkward
square where there were all kinds of
stalemate tricks
i think is going to get his first win of
the day right here i will finally call
it we see hikara smiling he agrees
it's time to throw in the towel the big
fish earned it
the first big w and uh he will not go
winless on the dead
but this is what is so impressive about
hit car is obviously he's winning all
these games
that position you know a lot of these
players would just consider resigning
at the start of it he lost the bishop he
blundered a full bishop
but he card made that as difficult as
possible and
if you played that same ending over say
20 times i'm sure he would score a
couple of draws based on
the time situation and everything so
really you know and the snake trick was
real right i mean federal staff was
taking his time for a reason he got
under time pressure because
you know hikaru creates a lot of
problems for his opponents we say it a
lot him and
him and magnus win more games than
they're not supposed to
dr evil fingers precisely because of
what you just saw the skill right there
and magnus we saw you know hammer and i
kept saying yet again
are telling me if outplays magnus to
come up with a loss right and that was
what happened
multiple times in today's match and you
know again it's
so we're you know we're giving credit
where credit's due there's a reason that
that
that it's so hard to win against those
guys um
but he does get his win by the way he's
on the board
and knight h4 the open file favors black
so fedo saves king not exactly feeling
the safest
over there on h2 not too many defenders
and you're removing one of the essential
ones by trying to trade off that knight
and also removing the knight makes d4
loose
i was going to say this position federal
safe has to be super careful
close to equal right now but there is a
long distance relationship
waiting to make it the real thing like
should we move to seattle where you live
or houston where i live yeah well
seattle has great things to do outdoors
yeah but it's cloudy all
right okay man you're so muddy though
what i said okay meg ryan
and they're like all right you know what
we're gonna do instead of making us
choose we're gonna move to a new
city we're moving to cleveland
f2 long distance relationships that work
you find a new city that's a pro tip
sorry i'm sorry i don't know where that
came from but
yeah you know you went with it you never
stopped i didn't give up
it's like i'm gonna keep telling it to
the last person in the room
is feeling awkward about it all right
seriously though
this does you do have to be careful here
because white's
positioned well defended right now all
of black's pieces are primed and ready
to hop over to the kingside this kind of
pawn chain is very
indicative of a coming kingside attack
if you
trade the queens though then white's
position gets good so
the attack whoa okay have you taken f2
h6
is oh not knight f6 okay so there's all
these ideas the
d7 was hanging that's why the rook
didn't take on f2
and knight f6 now becomes a threat
because the rook
is no longer attack so let's say it
trades everything off but you made a
good point if the queens are traded now
we like white in fact
trade and then f4 might even just be
better
better for white in the end game because
white will quickly own the e-file
um
i like it probably also considering f3
here okay he goes for the trade
i expect f4 to be played
f4 danny is one of those moves where
it's good with the rooks on the board
it may not be as great with the rooks
off the board because
the black king will just venture into
the center and the d5 pawn
which is advanced and restricting some
of uh the territory that black controls
but it can become a weakness and is
harder to defend
so look at hikaru gov fe-5 there could
be a rook f1
which just pins the bishop on the first
rank
so federer is thinking about that wow
oh he goes for it this could be a
turnaround
e6 okay this is this is the road for
fedor say of either getting his second
win in a row
or or losing what maybe would have been
a two result position
c6 just can't move by akaru trying to
remove the defender of this past pawn
and
fetishive will have time not right now
because you would lose the d5 pawn with
the tempo but
he can protect d5 and like b3 bishop b2
i guess that's his uh
main point yeah this is the key point to
unwinding
but now there's ideas of takes takes and
rook c8 yeah he goes for it
okay hold the phone you can't actually
take the bishop because e7 would then
promote the pawn so
he has that one move to get it right
makes me wonder if there was an idea
there obviously the eval bar helps i
wonder if bishop e3 sack in the exchange
was something that white had
um with these but no maybe not um
so actually how does hikaru deal with
this because
if white gets bishop b2 in yeah then
there will be eventual
rook g4 type of ideas in addition to
that past e
pawn this spells trouble for hikaru
speaking of long-distance relationships
that work right
yes indeed
i i not quite seeing a way out for a car
he's spending time he's very focused
right now
and federal save i wasn't sure if he was
frozen but he's not i saw his eyes
moving
he's also locked in just focused
so i think a car is trying to figure out
can he throw in a bishop g1
check is it even worth looking at that
bishop on c1 or is white just getting
bishop b2 in which case
i need to come up with a different type
of plan but bishop g1 check encourages
the king out to g3 or
some kurdish forces out there then you
can throw in a bishop f2 check the king
is going on a bit of a journey
for white if you're trying to win the
game
yeah this is a hard position you see
hikaru's focus there for a reason right
and
moves like king f8 hardly work right you
make the trade and then white's coming
to f4 and f7 this is
i mean understandable why hecarim makes
a mistake i i don't know how i would
have played
that position as as black
yeah and higher shakes his head i think
he was looking at some kind of rook c2
doubling on the second rank but then e78
comes too fast so this is just
yeah this is well now bishop takes d6 is
a threat if it weren't check because the
bishop is finn by the way rook takes c5
might actually be a threat
take it right now do it or take c5 and
take d6 ask questions later
i think it works yeah these these two
pawns are too much
do it there you go i mean you thought
about it you got down to seven seconds
that might cost you you got to move
quickly now e7
and the point is after rookie eight
there's rook f4 and then rook ffa check
ah you head to f8 and it's over
so fed us about to take his second game
in a row unless something goes
really wrong in the next couple seconds
yeah i don't think icarl can stop it
looking forward it's over wow
well i mean when we were highlighting
artemia's match versus magnus carlson we
consistently talked about
the magical way to beat magnus is you've
got to win two games in a row you got to
put him
in a position of psychological tilt um
now unfortunately for fedo say that has
come after he was down eleven to two
eleven to one actually but uh by the way
this is a horrible system for black
uh if i don't say a blunder d5 is a bad
move i
this reminds me of i used to play this
system and i got a win against gabriel
schwartzman you remember who gabriel
sportsman is
i know the name american grand master
um i caught him at the tail end of his
career let's say that right got a dub
against the g and uh it was in this
exact line
d5 is a blunder let's go to the analysis
board just to show it
it's actually a really funny trick
because even grand masters fall for it
and the staunton gamut with e4
uh there are multiple moves g6 e6 knight
c6 is actually the theoretical best
but d5 loses to this queen check because
you lose d5 and with it the e4 pawn
falls
black is just down a pawn and white is
doing well
although to fetishize credit despite
playing a subpar
opening it's getting complicated right
the king on c1 isn't exactly the
safest that you've seen a king be but
the king of g7 is no better and bishop
e6 offering exchange
oh no you couldn't take any six there
because queen a3 check
oh wow let's show it six fails to
check and lady falls with the discovery
what a nice little trick
the fedoce bounces back a little bit
white is still up a pawn and doing okay
but
anyway to complete what we were saying
dude fettle say i've got two wins in a
row that's what you got to do when
you're the underdog
make the favorite prove he can survive
tilt
unfortunately for fedo save it came
maybe too little too late
um but we'll see who knows you got a
third win i'll tell you what
now you're cooking and yeah
i mean you talked about salmon so
cooking something that you enjoy
i also enjoy cooking but right now this
position
still has to be good for car you are up
a pawn and black's king is feeling
safer and safer and the reason why is
you have the queen on b3 staring on the
diagonal
you have the rook on e1 that's
challenged by the rook on e8 but black
has these two pieces the queen on a5
and the knight on b6 ready to jump into
the
game over here and actually photoshop
gives up the b7 pawn
saying when i lose a pawn i open a file
so go for it have at that pawn i want
the b file
to be opened to use it in hikaru's like
not gonna fool me with that but now
knight c3 forks the rook and the a2 pawn
wow rook d3 what a move there's no
rookie one
the knight has no defense you have to
back up to a4
and then you might see hikaru go for
this b7 pawn
it might be chow time
like this even probably oh that loses to
rookie one and mate dan
hey don't check yourself on the back
rank dan was my nickname in high school
so i'm gonna not do that
you also are just the king of nicknames
yeah yeah
although rookie one doesn't work anymore
because after the takes white still has
queen to be
better saved trying his best but queen
b5
should do the trick i think for hikaru
trades the queens off by force there it
is and
now you have a material advantage yeah
that's a tough one and a good rebounding
victory for hikaru i still don't agree
with a lot of the opening choices fido
say has been playing
given the match situation chad said i'm
hating on the dutch you're darn right
i'm hanging on the dutch
yet again the opening not the people um
i'm i'm telling anish
oh lol you don't need to tell him we
know that anisha has nothing better to
do than watch these shows
oh for sure and just create tons of
instagram posts
yeah is it their instagram tweet one
thing he's not going to be doing is
working on his chess
wait he's actually playing at a
tournament now that i think about it is
he
yeah he had he scored a a really nice
win yesterday against wong hao
it shows how much you pay attention to
your friend
i think i did see that but you know
by the way the uh the b-bond eval bar
likes white
just a little bit those pawns
yeah b7 b8 seems
that's going to do the trick
and there it is
oh look we have more italian
it's awesome when you get silent on me
you know i can just
i can tell you're looking you're like
this again one more time for
it's for the crowd
um this is not your normal italian what
happened here
this was a game between was this a
magnus
hicaro game during one of their many
matches
this year yeah i think they had a game
either
in this exact position or very similar
to this
go to the batcave again i got to see the
opening now you inspired the chess
player in me again way to go
oh i care i'm sorry i'm sorry that you
care
yeah i'm sorry i made you care brad
[Laughter]
you always do that karen well this
game's getting
pretty wild yeah we got an italian
bishop e5 we've seen this many times
actually
jokes aside this was the lavonna ronian
versus
sorry the mbl versus lavon aronian many
times yesterday queen to b8 was played
multiple times by lev against maxine
so this morning with d4 and then the d5
counter shot to open e4 okay
again yeah i jokes aside just so you
know this is kind of funny i'm going to
secretly surprise you
i actually am trying to start playing
the italian instead of dutch so i've
been paying very close attention both to
yesterday and today i want
i wanted to see the opening difference
hence the mental note i made that the
move bishop b6 was the
difference in the variation between this
game and aronian's approach
you are an inspiration to the masses i
hope you know that i'm i'm
trying to start playing the italian it's
what every top player plays and
everyone keeps making fun of my scotch
yeah just
the fact that you are on the road to
recovery is
really something that everybody's happy
to hear
well you know what they say bless the
broken road as long as it leads to a
good result and i am hoping for that you
just
rascal flats me i just rascal flats the
bleep out of you
oh my gosh no one even likes pop country
anyway
we have never been closer than that
moment
because the broken road that led me
straight to you
and well if you look at this position
danny that rook on b3
can head straight over to the king side
in a moment's notice with rook g3 there
it is
and this could be a problem for hikaru
as
there is an attack building it's been a
good italian for fedo save and by the
way it's been a good italian all day
regardless of the scoreboard he's had
pretty good positions as white
you've got this isolated d pawn and then
the four on three white structure is
much healthier
and as robert said there's uh potential
for something over here
i'm guessing a4 gets played oh no he
goes for the pawn i didn't think he
could do it he does it
he's a greedy greedy lad yeah he'll put
the queen on e2 and say you know what i
grabbed a pawn i'm gonna own it
and the i think what you were
highlighting there is that it gives
black the active counter play
yeah and white has his extra pawn e5 but
you can't really mobilize the pawns just
yet it's more about the potential attack
and pickard needs to find a couple moves
here rook d4 is a good start
stopping queen e4 where the bishop and
the queen would line up for a checkmate
threat
and so now you can double the rooks in
the d file and try to
take over uh the activity
yeah it's a great point and since we're
on the announcement still i'll just back
up again that was partly why i like day
four and i'm not sure it's any better
than grabbing the pawn but i like the
idea of keeping the tension
because the deep one's not going
anywhere just felt like this bishop kind
of lacks a purpose if that's the case
but
all right we're in the live position
here better save
is well he's no longer up upon black
stole a4
whoa oh a2 sorry
that was unexpected but why not there's
no way to punish it
look at that oh look at that if you take
with the bishop rook b1 is coming
but how do you continue this because you
can play bishop c2 here
as even though it puts the bishop on a
hanging square the bishop on b3 is
pinned
but he goes rook this is steps in the
wrong direction
you can tell you don't really sacrifice
both your queenside pawns and then play
rook to e3
which doesn't actually have a concrete
threat
well it has rookie iv as an awkward
threat right because if you trade you
bring my queen to
her desired post i'm with you
no i'm with you federal state is going
the wrong direction and now the threat
on d2 is leading to one direction thank
god harry styles left him
but um that's the second rank
the second rank is black for the taking
and there goes cecaro
i almost want to play e7 here for white
just like push the pawn
he goes for it he goes for it but it was
just a loss
rook takes a five you get the queen what
in the world
because i'm with you
he's like what i mean how many extra
pawns does black have three
yeah this is this is bad news
i thought you were about to ask a riddle
how many extra pawns does it take to you
know
to beat to beat a big fish um
seems like you want to answer that
question i i don't know the answer but
queen c2 seems to be a start because
it's a double attack of f2 and b1
um oh by the way if queen of queen of
two there was bishop d5 to follow
how's that sapping now i was teaching
one not just crushing it is bishop d5 to
follow like
owie
in the words of the illustrious dr evil
ouch bibbles i don't know if you were
watching earlier
it just came out of me i you know
everyone has a little fat bastard inside
him and i said
you can keep you i'll get there
wait i i just it wasn't dr evil it was
gold member wasn't it
oh yeah goldfinger goldfish ouch can
bibbles
yeah yeah does he also say it
no oh i love this system i love b5
officially rooting for fedocia because
of the opening hold it
it's dubious for black i think you're
rooting for people
what kind of unbiased commentator are
you i just if they play an opening i
love
i want a result
okay there you go it's a bononi
with gusto you're like i'm not sitting
around i'll play a6
sort the structure d6 i've i didn't ask
to play b5 in this position you know
what i did i saw the opening
and i took it okay
took it yes i don't want you're like
that's what this opening's about
of course of course the major issue now
is look at the c4 square that is
permanently whites for the taking
cannot kick that pony out from there
black's bishop on f8
is extremely strong and i don't mean
that seriously
it's staring it to its own pawns this is
no good
i love how you go right to just telling
me how why this opening is so bad
um you know when you hit me with a
varsity blues reference what do you want
that's right
well i'm gonna go right back at you i'm
gonna play g6 move the knight punch f5
and this looks pretty now we'll see if
you can use it
um the real threat is actually to bring
the knight to c6
i guess that's your new nickname do they
call you mox in high school too
not quite back in high school i could
throw pigskin
that's i'm more more compared to uncle
rico than anyone else in my life
g6 and f5 is coming it is the system i
like though seriously
wait what's this though hey this looks
really bad
nakamura's put on a clinic i've had to
bust my opening this is not looking good
no it's not eight by five i just lost
completely lost for me money for you
remember you're not playing you're
commentating yeah
sometimes you forget i do from time to
time
um but seriously we are having a great
time it's a ten game lead for nakamura
i'm gonna guess it gets to be even a
little bit more before we move to bullet
officially this is the last game though
uh shout out to everyone who wants to
subscribe with your prime throw us
your prime because it's time for the
primetime smackdown coming up see what
happens in the next games between me and
donya naradiski
um and more prime time matches uh coming
up
in our next scc shows and other big
events
um yeah man
this is this is wild i mean we're having
a good time and we're lucky to get to do
what we do even if it's a lopsided match
but i'm i'm just so impressed by icaro
today
and i won't play this opening anymore if
that's what you want to hear
that does make me happy to hear that
you're improving your openings
but also hikaru just even these little
moments
uh a couple moves ago he didn't
recapture and
most chess players would they get away
with the analysis board because what
were you just saying about the recapture
right i missed that
on move uh after 16 b takes c3 by
ferocious yeah people are reactionary
after b takes c3 most people just take
back and don't think twice but the car
went
b3 because he said my knight on c4
is a bit loose and i want to move my
knight from a5 into c6
i'll win the c3 pawn later more
important is just improving my knight's
locations
and then the knights go to town
seriously what an instructive idea
b3 you guard the knight eyeing that the
square and the tempo is more important
than the pawn on c3
and ikaru starts winning material
because of it
last move queen to d5 is going to force
an engine with a couple of pass pawns i
would want nothing to do with if i was
fedo save
um wow
i don't know what to say now what do we
do did you talk to each other
yeah i know but it was awkward
ugh
all right there are three past pawns on
the bar dude there's
that's a lot yeah too many of them i i
didn't like the silence but i didn't
want to be the first one to speak so oh
man
speed chess championship delivering
again in many different ways today again
this is the second of our double header
if you missed magnus carlson versus
vladislav artemyev
lucky for you it will be available uh on
youtube
and on twitch um forget if our videos on
twitch are only for subscribers i don't
know but either way it's available on
twitch and youtube
and you can check it out and hear hikaru
nakamura and our second match of the day
is putting on
a show he is indeed
um look at these this pawn chain
too many pawns better say
hoping that something can work out for
him but there's
nothing here is there
someone goes i'm still laughing at the
varsity blues reference
at least i made the appropriate
reference for that movie and not the one
that's normally made
yes i mean you know exactly what i'm
talking about
i could pretend that i don't just so
you'll do it but i am going to
acknowledge that yes i do know
oh man oh man
g4 everyone james van der beek was a
thing yeah
you were definitely a dawson's creek guy
gotta be kidding me dude if i was i
would have been on purse team percy not
team dawson for the record
wait he just gave his rook on c3 wait
and he'd
take it because the d-pawn that was nice
it doesn't matter
if you take c5 everyone hikari was gonna
sack and play d7 it's dirty it's wrong
but it's happening
oh man
remember that joshua jackson's name and
that show was perfect
that's going way back even for me i'm
gonna i'm gonna brag to my wife about
that later
because let's be honest she was probably
into percy and dawson on seventh
evan 7th heaven right before on the wb
right before 7th heaven you have
dawson's creek
i'll tell you what we are going to have
an awesome last 30 minute segment don't
go anywhere everyone it's time for the
prime
time smackdown and hess and i will be
right back
don you look over there there's a thing
that just happened mess with your mic
for a little bit
there is a thing that just happened why
isn't his time running
crap my time i no it was i was hate
thinking about that we don't just start
the time of the moves when i want to
beat somebody and i appreciate that we
do it
but it's a good thing i was connecting
my good mouse because that's what's
needed to beat you
i can't just use any old mouse i've got
to use the danny wrench killer mouse
really yeah that feels so good when you
say it like that
no i you gotta have specialized
equipment to beat danny lynch you also
got to get a good night on that before i
feel
this is like the worst white side of a
caro con in the history of
white sides of the caro khan you do have
some pretty good well it's all pawns and
no talk but sometimes that's a good
thing
all pawns and no talk no all pawns are
no hope it's the correct queen's game no
hope oh no hope okay
yeah all pulled still hope it wasn't oh
i totally believe you look at that
that was a wonder look at that all right
emergency measures okay that little
piece you just gave me how about that
yeah if only you didn't have that knight
on uh night on e5 i would be in good
shape
oh man no i thought i won more
look at your horrible bishop
yeah i honestly can't move here wow by
the way can you appreciate that i just
i just dominated your face facial face
facial are we gonna make this about
faces because i can
definitely make it about you just got
crushed bro you might as well
have taken the l in that game as my 15
year old say he would say take the l dad
take the l you know what i see is 0.5
uh and and that as far as i remember
indicates a drawn game
and that was a money decision which you
just did there that was that was awesome
i think i'll do more of that taking the
draws and positions up with these
positions that are completely winning
for you um i don't know why i did
how about that that was a great move too
maybe i should repeat moves now
take a page out of danny wrench's face
uh book
[Music]
i know that i do feel the pain i'm going
to do the unethical thing and text my
wife back and let myself lose on time
i just have to sit there for 30 seconds
instead of doing anything else
girl i'd love to sit there for 30
seconds and admire my position
i mean this is amazing back to my wife
yes ma'am i will do what you asked me to
do
i resigned you can go answer that
doorbell that just rained no i've
resigned
i'm not playing anymore you can walk
resign you can walk away i'm telling you
all right i have one more chance i'm so
upset that i let you off at that draw
the comeback of the century begins now
and we are back here in a match that has
uh
has been full of statements by the
defending champion and the number one
overall seed
ikar nakamura leads 11 to three
and uh hess and i were talking off air
there's just it's
just uh it's been dominant it's been
crazy it's been
you know you're disappointed for
federosay of a guy that's had an
incredible year by the way right and and
so so consistent in the speeches grand
prix
um and and many other events but wow
hikaru nakamura has shown up today and
shown up big time
as he looks to fill out the bracket in
front of us right now robert
yeah i mean it's clear at this point he
is going to move on to face wesley so
in the semi-finals and danny before this
whole
event started if you said that hikaru
nakamura wesley so
magus carlson maxine rashtray lagrave
were in the final four
i think that probably would have been
the picks of most people and there was
fantasy so
i'm sure people did fill the brackets
with these four i'm guessing it's the
most common
uh we sure know what these gears did
anish anish geary took vladislav artimus
to beat him by four points
beat himself do you know that yeah i
know
yeah it's hilarious he was objective
wasn't he but then he was objective
was there collusion in he's like he
can't beat artemia are you kidding me
he's just like you he speaks about
himself from the third person right
do you think he'd also watch seventh
heaven does he know the candid family
yeah that's probably where he got his
good american pop culture knowledge as a
kid right spent a little too much time
watching the old wb on dutch radio
network he had to hit the box a few
times to get it to relay
all right well we have it kara nakamura
with an 11 game lead
uh sporting his lucky hoodie against
vladimir fedorosev who will be burning
that hoodie the moment the match is over
let's do it it's bullet time i do like
the hoodie though for both of them
but uh right now hikaru his rating 34
15 and bullet fetishes at a lowly
obviously joking
30-78 oh we get this line ooh
they should eat two no this is okay
nutty
i like it for white though
he knows the theory yeah he doesn't seem
to mind one bit here
yep white's pawn structure is stable but
the bishop on b6
doesn't look that great right now but
watch for the knight from to move from
c6 black to push the pawn
on the c file and free up that bishop to
a better diagonal in the future yep
and sometimes i was gonna say even
bishop a5 is a subtle awkward move to
watch out for
um ecardo has brought all the pieces to
the king's side gonna try to use the c4
square
that's true right he can place c6 first
and brings bishop back
there's there was a threat of knight d7
so the car regarded that now he'll play
c6 and relocate
if you trade the c4 square opens up
right so g4 now hits the queen where's
that queen going the c8 i guess
a sad retreat is rook f2
wow tough you know what i don't like
what you highlighted before i could say
it we're in the same
same wavelength it literally gave me
indigestion talking about the bishop
you know not to you know promote
anything but a pepto bismol might do
this
yeah pepto-bismol um not a sponsor of
the show
no certainly not besides i prefer tomes
okay
um rook to e2 played again this bishop
is bad this knight is good
um small b6 prevents bishop c5
it's painful look at the
dynamics though the pawns four on two
from the e3 h file and then the same
in black's favor from the a to the d
file so interesting
to note that the king on g8 in is less
safe than the king on h2 watch out for
some
future ideas with f5 and here it comes
yeah he's preparing it in fact yeah this
is turned around i was
loving the the knights dominance of the
bishop earlier but not anymore
that'll save if he can punch f5 this is
a different game
for sure and he's actually playing
really quickly he's up seven seconds
counting down now but he
built up a lead in the clock and that's
rare against nakamura
he wants to d3
love to just play g4
there are trick on e5 no there's none
okay bishop h4 and i can't get g4
because f4 is hanging right now
so rook f2 first but if this move comes
in and you can slide the bishop back to
g3 suddenly f5 is a real threat
here he goes he's going to slide the
bishop back and try to manufacture this
idea
this looks very good f5 push him
oh yeah but arnold's breaking through
first who's better here and why i
no idea i would maybe bring the queen
all the way back oh b3 even nicer
because it pinned the knight
so rook takes c5 he does it oh he wins
the pawn but the d-pawn's rushing
knight if one check that's the big deal
oh you couldn't play rook d2 because of
the fork
oh so you oh so you wow if you take just
a queen happens a queen appears and
blocks a head i don't understand why
it's only plus two for black like what
because the knight trap wait rook takes
f1 and they work
no yeah you have rookie eight there's no
check by the queen
yeah but oh he promotes first
i think they just played like the most
accurate way to play the position too
that was bananas that they figured that
out
and if black can't win this because if
you take b3 you lose a5
oh he just tricked him the pin
bishop d2 was a mine a land mine square
let's show it on the analysis board real
quick that's a landmine tactic
the bishop was ideally placed but he
puts it
on a square that is pinned to the king
and acaro doesn't have to be asked twice
if you take it was a draw
but he plays a4 and you can't take
because rook b2 would win the piece
and so white is just dead lost to the
coming a takes b3
wow what a move what a finish
icaru is now up 12 games
i'm just he is really playing some
phenomenal
chess today and in this current game
this position i've had from the white
side many times
you want to dislodge the queen from d5
and then push d5 yourself
to open up that bishop on b2 that's your
uh kind of the pride and joy
of the future of the position here
bishop c1 he said re-routes it because
there were threats of bishop to h3 so
maybe he wasn't quite able to
get that plan in order
to page five play chases the queen here
goes bishop e3 to defend d4
no bishop b2 because he still has
aspirations
of d5 and the knight protected the
bishop
but as was the case before d5 is not
bishop h3 that's why he put his king in
the corner
but now bishop e6 stops d5 before it can
happen
this is important it's an isolated pawn
you want to blockade
these isolated queen pawns and that is
exactly what fedocer is doing
he should be slightly better in this
position
the car looking a little frustrated with
his position there
but we'll d oh f4 that's a move
yeah committal yeah
might have been a little impatient too i
was wondering if he had kind of fixed
his problems if he just backed up the
bishop but
now he's got double attacks on d5 and
f7 wow look at fedo
speaking of committal
as you would say honey badger don't care
yeah
the adventure takes what he wants that's
exactly what he's doing oh you can't
take on g4 with the bishop because queen
of seven mate
and if you take with the queen there's
queen f6 you take with the queen
queen f6 if you take with the bishop
queen of seven's mate
i know the computer says equal but i
have no idea what to play here is black
what a freaking move here comes queen of
six oh
always
in the bishop c5 check coming is that
the idea
that was set if king ji won bishop c5
and if the king runs out here comes now
black is winning oh my gosh
we take holy bleep
that'll save the monster he's gonna go
rook takes b2 next
oh my god rook g2 oh he just takes the
bishop
g5 and he's of g5
okay so hikaru has been brilliant all
matched this was
to my eyes the best game yeah this was
this was maybe the game of the match in
bullet
um queen takes g2 out of nowhere
and as long as he finishes it off i
guess look at hicaro doing what he does
best making it an absolute mess despite
being dead lost
yeah he's he's and it's completely
busted hard to call it the game of the
match if he doesn't win but as long as
said it finishes that that bishop that
queen g2 was just
nasty wait wasn't it oh bishop was
pinned i was like what's there yeah yeah
yeah
is coming now though uh oh he oh no
he's only got three seconds though and
we know how tricky the queen is in these
cases one second
yeah oh no
he lost spawn
maybe
he wants to make a net bishop f7 is a
threat
bishop f7 would be a threat but that's
why i put his queen on e4 there
oh he's got richie five now yes he stops
it
what is happening i don't see how black
can win this take on a
five no can you do it he does it yeah he
does it
and he's gonna bring his king oh then
he's gonna get rid of the v4 pawn
wow wow
that was the game and then it wasn't
i still think it's the game of the match
what does it cardo do that
seriously that was just like
retake g2 was just sick
like most people just think about
resigning oh i'm getting checkmated
fedozer says not so fast i am going to
sack my queen out of nowhere that was so
incredible and then hikaru
holds that position absolutely no
business doing so getting mated probably
at some point with the rook and bishops
wow crazy crazy stuff what a great game
and like we said the one minute segment
would not disappoint regardless of how
you feel about the scoreboard
um i don't know what's going on here but
uh better say of
king side's falling apart yeah it is
it's he's playing these lines that i
have played
plenty of times myself not very good for
white so i continue to play it
knowing full well it's not good look at
your e3 square your h4 pawn
yeah black is perfectly safe to sound
the center and
wait knight takes queen d6 is coming
dark squares are coming winter is here
between d6 yeah
sorry that came out of nowhere what
because the queen g through his mate if
you move the knight i know and i was
shaking my head because i didn't know
what else to do sometimes my emotions
my therapist told me it's okay to haven
and just like rub yourself when you're
overwhelmed
they present damn yeah it's okay to do
those things when you're not in the
middle of a broadcast
okay when i'm not in the middle of the
match i'll remember that
i knew queen v6 was coming there was no
way to stop it
i'm still thinking about that marvelous
queen takes g2 check
let me take g2 that that's that was so
nasty
and i just i want to know where the
force wind was in my head
for my own sanity but um
wow
but as as this as the show has been all
day it didn't matter because i
found a way to get the draw in that game
yeah
it's just really incredible that even in
games that were like okay fedo say has
done it you know
he got the lead here in that individual
game and then nope hikaru is fighting
back taking a pawn here giving a check
there
creating problems for fetose that he
just can't fully solve so
it's unbelievable stuff
now we are what
in a position that neither side is happy
to play i'll say that
what's going on with this pawn chain you
would love to play rook
a1 to g1 that's your best move jump that
rook
over everything yep but good luck doing
that
and actually for black if you can you're
going to take this bishop on c1
if you can somehow get your bishop to h6
yeah and that bishop
e3 e3 is calling my name and fedo say if
here's the cry
okay timothy chalamet
i like to uh when i cry queen oh my gosh
oh i almost called you the gordon ramsay
what i meant to call you the uh mason
uh ramsay
oh look at b5 though speaking of calling
my name
light squares are also on the agenda for
recaro so
queen h5 threatens queen of three
don't want to allow that check you pick
up the rook next
oh wait uh queen b5
might not have been with the doctor
order because now you can't really stop
queen f3
it's a quick queen of three is going to
be between three rook up two is mate so
he has to run the king
so this d3 pawn is hanging and the queen
on b1 was defending that so that's
probably
an important difference here yeah
probably all you should do is just take
the pawn
i think he's gonna try to get the bishop
in but i don't see what it does
right it feels a little bit slow either
settle on a perpetual or grab the d-pad
red pill or blue pill you choose oh look
he took the red pill
and i'm wondering if it's important that
the queen protects the rook on g8
probably not but the king won't there's
not a perpetual check
for white to work yeah i think it is
important
even if you end up walking over and
allowing a rook check on the g file for
a trade
oh but queen e7 yeah there's another jbs
bishop g5 too
wait
okay queen takes oh that pawn was
important
who's doing what here this is too
confusing
quiche five line those queen and bishop
up for a queen e3 check here comes
but hikar must have some kind of
repetition available to him yeah you
would think that the queen can hold on
the light squares the
geometry of the board says so wait what
oh wow hey carlo lost on time i've never
seen that happen before i've never seen
that happen before
seriously i i i
look like well that doesn't happen very
often
oh my gosh increment
yeah that was surprising he almost took
too much time
with queen of seven and knight knight h5
he was trying to figure out a win
instead of just settling on the draw
which
i guess when you're up you know 13 games
you can afford to do that
um but yeah he just lost track of time
happens to all of us and what's going on
here white is
has that sort of king's indian structure
where you press
uh forward on the queen side but are you
there in time that's an important
question
yeah because uh h4 is coming yeah you're
not gonna like it
yeah the h file a wee bit of a problem
uh oh in comes the queen
pg four first which four looks good but
you should take the four
quinn because h3 queen h2 check and then
if queen e4 this queen issue and then
queen each one trading the queen's off
and
winning the rook on a1 at the end oh wow
we need four you check twice everyone
the trade has to happen and a skewer is
your uncle on a1
i think it's over because there's a
double attack here
yeah it's not just g3 it's it's this
idea so as long as cecaro sees that
game i get you know he'll do he'll play
king e2 and give up the rook and try for
something on the game
is there maybe but carl was considering
taking here because of that exact idea
i mean i think was the best he goes for
it wait what look at that
he goes king e2 i didn't know it was
gonna be a draw but that's the idea
what is it all right oh queen e6 now
going 27 mate or queen 26th threatens 27
mate and queen f7
oh my gosh allison
oh my god the email bar is going nuts
he gave c6 and he's holding oh 25.
devastating devastating
how many times are you gonna repeat what
i have to say
honestly i thought that you just
couldn't hear me earlier i just thought
that you would
you're such a child that's the next
thing you say
oh man that was nuts right there
seriously
hey karu goes queen h1 and king e2 and
somehow white was holding there
but he went to the wrong square on d3
which allowed the whole queen b5 check
if he had stayed on d1 all black has
dude is a perpetual because of the mate
that's crazy right
let's i'll show it on the analysis board
real quick real quicky
the losing move was king to d3
if you stay here the point everyone is
you have to take a draw
because if rook d8 then queen f7 is made
there's no way to guard queen d7 mate
coming so the losing move was king to d3
oh my gosh it's not fair it's not fair
it's not fair hello well you're going to
try to go
it's so funny if they could see your
face off camera you said it's not fair
and then you gave this smile like
danny and i both know i'm not going to
be able to do this i don't want to do it
yes you're
absolutely right you couldn't be as
immature as me if you tried
no i i couldn't you're a hundred percent
so i i don't try
also this is one of the weirder rook
lifts ever like there's a bishop still
what happened here just
brooke wanted to get in the game yeah
oh this looks bad white's up a pawn
the f file is he cars for the taking
rook d
to f is meant by knight h7 with a fork
that would be sick
that's a fork a4 full board awareness
thank you very much now rook takes a
seven
oh i thought he would just take right
away yeah i think carl should have taken
right away shook his head
he's just playing too well right now
but we still have about 8 000 on youtube
25k on twitch don't go anywhere
interviews with the players after the
games are finished
we'll talk about the semi-finals robin
and i preview what we think will be two
epic match-ups
between magnus and mbl
icaru nakamura and wesley so um
don't look now d7 hanging blunted it
aw snap it happened again
[Laughter]
again wisconsin um that was perfectly
timed
it literally happened right in front of
me
uh if someone doesn't clip that you have
no soul
five of you should clip that
oh god seriously
and look hours look at the nice finish
of the game too
we think it's oh my god rook a7
sick yeah have they even started the
next game yet
um yeah they have oh my
you are just adorable um you know i'm
just trying to uh
give a little shout out to jennifer
coolidge she deserves it
yeah the unnecessary shout out to
jennifer coolidge that every chess show
needs
every chess show gets a shout out to
sheboygan i mean how many people know
about sheboygan
i would go this way every single time is
one of the most underrated
okay craft beer rear beer capitals of
the world thank you very much
it sounds like you've had a few because
you can't even say the word it's been
eight hours
under these lights and you know how it
is to do the sec this isn't over the
board candidates
you know where you get to take seven
breaks yeah
you're talking about the lights now you
really are going full varsity
it's been a long day it's been a lot of
fun too
yeah yeah not a lot of fun for
fedo save right now you know what why
don't you just finish this one without
me buddy
turn the lights off well i can
commentate this and we see
your screen it's lit in a very dark room
and danny
what are you doing over there wait no i
don't want to see you again on the
camera you want to see the full screen i
can show you
what i'm doing over here i got my chat
over here this is where i got twitch
youtube i got slack and our run of show
doc
the road of show doc we're very
professional i scroll through my google
sheet we mark off items with strike
through text who doesn't love strike
through text makes you feel like you did
something
right right through the text we get down
to our we're now down here right we're
in the uh the last portion of the show
that's our run of show what and it's in
comics
it's in comic sans if you don't use
comic sans what are you reading
okay scc quarterfinals the show anyway
then i got the big uh the big
monitor over here on the other side
where i'm doing the chess
well hello darkness my old friend it's
good to see you back here danny
here we go hikaru here we go i've
totally
lost sight of the chest because of
everything that's just been happening
here you've succeeded
it's ruined me but hey caro succeeded i
mean this is just
you know there's really little that can
be said at this point obviously we can
talk about the specifics of the
individual chess games but
19 and a half to four and a half yep
not what i thought was gonna happen you
know how much i'm on tilt that i'm
literally singing sean mendes in my head
have mercy on me
take it easy on my heart even though you
don't have to get 20.
carl nakamura i'm falling apart have
mercy
mercy and then you punch shawn mendes in
the face and say you're the most
irritating male pop singer since gavin
degraw
whoa what do you got against gavin
degraw always i don't like that
either but where did that come from like
you don't like sean minnes you talk
about this every single time
you did a pretty yeah you're pretty nice
too in there i'll give you that
uh but i had another thought now what oh
we're smarter chess
oh no don't worry about him
we locked him in the basement he's
pumping out semi-finals predictions as
we speak
um all right but seriously we're gonna
have great interviews this has been an
awesomely fun day
chess is the most entertaining thing on
twitch everyone knows it by the way if
you happen to be watching chess for the
first time hit that follow button
um we cover everything here the biggest
events in the world not always
this much of a lopsided pop culture
hysterical show
um anyway does d4 move yeah look at that
fetose
whoa
there's seven minutes remaining in this
match oh my god i gotta focus
okay so fetish takes the e5 pawn but he
is
even in terms of material but that king
of g8 that rook on h8 is entombed over
there it's stuck
wants to get out desperately and you
need to play king h7 but that walks into
an even bigger attack so not easy for
fedor save to coordinate all his pieces
not easy at all slave to chess on chess
tv said candles would be nice for our
studio in the dark lit room
we should get some scented candles it
does i do get a little sweaty in here
under the light so scented candles might
add to the ambiance we'll do that thank
you slave to chess
i'm not giving you a premium membership
because you trolled yesterday's show
pretty bad so if you were a better basic
member i would reward you
need a username i love you oh my gosh
um anyway this looks very bad for
fedocera because all of a sudden the
attack is
is on the g7 square you should probably
play h5 for black to keep the g
file closed but that doesn't look very
enticing because now look at g6 it's not
over
and your king stuck then the rook is
stuck as well and e6 is weak
f4 but the knight on d5 is so you like
black's position if it wasn't for the
fact that the king and rook
aren't playing um
now e6 will be traded for g6 that's
fedor saves hope here everybody
one last chance at a dub is what he's
thinking but he might just lose a piece
instead with rookie one and bishop c5
a wee bit of a problem yeah yeah so is
your accent but other than that
everything's
perfect in the world yeah and the
pandemic that's a problem
well i did sing shawn mendes for the
first time on a chess tv show it wasn't
enough to deter hikaru from getting 20
points despite the begging for mercy
um and uh
there you go yeah
it's uh it's a tough day for photosafe
seriously you know i mean we've had a
we've had a lot of fun and there have
been some really impressive and
instructive moments but overall like
just not what we saw coming right and
it's not like shade dejkar
or fedo say it but just like this has
been a dominant semi-par
semi-final performance and hikaru making
a statement
yep and he really is just
he's unstoppable look at that he doesn't
take the h3 knight after
bishop was captured he takes on g3 first
opening the position up
sacrificing a piece because bishop g2
was possible there
if white wanted to keep the material
it's funny because it's probably not a
sound sacrifice and we see that if white
just plays bishop g2 here which
photosafe does he has queen f3 next
but you know there's 95 ideas you can
just keep chomping on pawns
if you want them for karu it's not like
white's king will ever
find total shelter
so how ooh e5
that's a move i like it i would say how
can black castle queen said quickly and
the answer is you can't
this is nuts it almost looks like fedo
say have played the bond cloud
something you expect the person leading
the match to do with the king on f2 what
is going on
uh oh well here it comes once there was
the king castles this is
very good news here comes knight takes
d4
and the g don't check all right don't
forget bishop g4 check
good call dan don't forget bishop g4
pinning
all damn are you calling me dan
i don't know
i c3 you're gonna play rookie one he did
get out of the pressure there so i
thought hikaru's attack was gonna roll
but somehow he keeps it tricky
and watch out for knight things be seven
and then creepy five check was coming
oh god double check him queen c8 mate
that's a problem dude it's nasty because
the bishop guards d6 so knight d6 check
and queen c8 was mate
and he just takes the knight and gets
away with it because
okay now there's a mate coming on b7
does takara turn this one around two
i might just walk right out wait rook f3
check king e2
the bishop covers all the squares we've
broke no we're getting should i take him
broke up to a
key yeah who takes work of two kingdoms
he's safe
i think hikaru isn't
oh it's just winning the bishop now
which hits the rook on h8
uh uh-oh i saw that bar
i have no idea but it's it's he just
takes c5
i think he had rookie 3 and queen h4
maybe that was the idea anyway
either way doesn't matter although oh he
gets the four
forces the fork man oh he denies the
fork
go fork yourself he says
that was really nice oh my gosh
a couple of denied forking opportunities
not something that happens every day
oh man 92 check he could have won the
rook
oh he missed it another fork
okay but oh my goodness is still gonna
take this one
yeah he just won a rook wow he does
strike
and it may be his last chance because
only one game remains here hikara goes
back to the old number
one they say the old terminator right
we know that vaughn had the fastball
give me vaughan
right carlos got old number one with b3
okay but danny just one thing that
you're missing this whole equation
looking at cars rating right now oh he's
a below 2400 he's
rouge is sitting there like just
laughing right his own 17 year old self
like
they're all happy that he's now the
highest rated
yep the andrew tangs the daniel ditzkies
the farouzas they're pretty happy that
he
lost 10 points
and well now we have uh is this the last
game it is the last game
yeah i mean unless we see a blunder and
a nightmare in the next few seconds we
will have
about 25 000 of you sticking with us i
know you're all not going anywhere we
got interviews coming up and we still
got about 8 000 of you on youtube so
this has been a great day
and a very long day double scc
i couldn't have had it any other way to
reign in the speed the speedchest
semifinals which start next weekend
yeah those are going to be amazing
obviously four very deserving players
and for the pleasure eliminate today
artemia put up a great fight
against magnus carlsen and for fedo say
he wishes he could take this back but
he's just probably happy that he was
playing in this in the first place he's
always
just so appreciative of the
opportunities that he has every time we
interview him so
i am looking forward to hearing his
thoughts and what went wrong
and if he could restart the match maybe
what he would do differently
right
yeah he did beat farouja and what was a
bracket buster for a lot of people right
it took overtime but ali alireza faruja
has lost in the first round now both
this year and last year in 2019 to
lavonne aronian
so we know ferruja has a great future um
but
uh that'll say have sent him home this
year well queen takes e1 was winning
with rook c1
was it i know roxy won actually
immediately with queenie three check
where's that oh nice it was sick and he
missed it
is he going to get the dub anyway no
it's falling apart hey carl's bringing
rook d8
although rook takes e7 yeah there is
tactics everywhere
oh now rook takes us check oh
so it's over also the rook and he wants
protected so it's rook takes to it
a secondary problem he's forcing the
issue
um as long as you don't play king f1 and
allow bishop check yep and caro sees it
he tucks the king
safely to bed on the dark squares and
he's gonna take
the last game of this sec here winning a
piece
and should be the game these pawns are
are not enough
i don't even think you can keep the
pieces bishop b5 is my bishop d7
oh she's getting a queen i i was just
like yeah just get the queen but
and make him get up at bishop d7 is even
better yeah that's a problem
right he goes bob barker what's the
whole thing
i'm thinking of happy gilmore bob barker
totally different story
no that's exactly what it is i know i'm
just trying to make you
feel like i'm what he's won johnny
you only make a happy gilmore reference
probably one and a half times the
broadcast
you like no that's not true no you don't
oh
oh look at that move king c5 torturing
look at the way white's gonna win
everyone is with oh i thought he was
gonna go with irregular opposition
but maybe he thinks he can get back in
time because he's holding the f5 pawn
right and the f5 square covers b1 so he
takes on
f5 will put his bishop on b1 play pawn
to f1 oh my gosh
yeah the technique is accurate it's
super precise
as they say and hikaru takes this match
by a final score
of 22 and a half to five and a half
boy have we had a day if you are
one of a lot of people still here who's
been here all day seriously thank you so
much it's been it's been a lot of fun
robert and i will be right back enjoy
the final
segment of our prime time smackdown to
our subscribers we appreciate your
support
stay around for interviews and we will
be having those
in just a few minutes
the comeback of the century begins now
although i will point out you beat
almost everybody else 3-0 and
included didn't you beat hammer threo i
believe so
you know who you've never beaten 3-0 in
a smackdown wrench
whatever makes you feel good about
yourself man
i mean that was incredibly impressive
every time you talk
i feel less than stop talking down to me
talking to okay no more talking down
that just like that right there that was
what you just did
was exactly that i'm i'm getting under
your skin that's
that that's part of that's what i
learned from the greats gary kasparov
and
you know and company very important to
employ you know psychological
pressure on the opponent let's make him
get under your scheming movements
that's exactly what i'm doing has anyone
ever told you that your kasparov is so
freaking good
like that is one of the best gary
kasparov impersonations i've ever heard
in my life
i hate you for that move i appreciate
when i'm when i play
the real i am not not one of those danny
wrench
kind of items but levy i'm sure we'll uh
we'll exchange some impressions
oh you see as soon as i as soon as i
burn you there's a blunder
i feel so bad about myself right now i
feel bad i actually feel bad i'm being
mean
i need to stop being mean whoa oh look
at those moves
those primos are scary i know i can't
move as fast i feel like i'm like a like
steward for manchester look what i can
do
hey look what i can do almost down me
all right back to the old drawing board
for dan
indeed
and we are now joined by our players of
the second scc match of the day
icaru and vladimir thank you so much for
joining us
um vladimir starting starting with your
side we know obviously today did not go
the way you
the way you mapped out and and robert
and i didn't have a lot of questions
besides asking you
what would you have done differently
second time around obviously hikaru had
his a game today
but in hindsight now with a match that
got away from you pretty early
what would you have done differently in
terms of your approach
actually so much start with a huge
disconnection from my side and then
i got tilting so
i do i don't think that's in the world
we can name second player who is such a
good as hikaru
in the situation when your opponent
tilted and that's
that's why this is much ended how much
how it's ended and also he
he was so perfect concentrated
till the end of the match i found many
great practical ideas but
uh he always was
better physically mentally and
[Music]
again in the game now played me uh
in intense game
i mean hikaru from where we were sitting
i was saying
that you were really playing some of the
best chess i've seen from you
in this kind of speedchest championship
match format and as early as game two
you went
really active and kind of pounced on
vladimir
in that position did you have any
specific preparation because you have
acknowledged
how strong vladimir is and what a tough
opponent he can be for you
yeah so i mean first of all what i would
say is that um not not to like sort of
discredit my previous opponents but for
all the previous matches i
i didn't actually do any preparation
whatsoever um
whereas for this match i did quite a bit
of preparation and um
and so so credit to vladimir because he
is a very strong player and he did beat
ali reza
in the first round um yeah i think i
think to match
there were a couple things first of all
um i
i thought i played very very well i
think it was maybe the third game when i
had maybe
10 seconds and he had the minute or
something like this i thought the third
game i played very very well when i had
no time um
and so i played very well when i had
little time on the clock and i thought
that was probably the main thing i did
well in the five plus one
um but mainly it just things just seemed
to be working the preparation worked out
i got a lot of good positions um and i
mean it was
very strange because it felt like uh it
got away from vladimir probably
in the five plus one um but but yeah
that's how it goes sometimes
vladimir you you um to go to some extras
who knows you you played the italian
consistently and you seem to be getting
some pretty decent positions as white
uh regardless of of the final result was
that part of your prep
and um would you would you stick with an
opening like that consistently
uh given the the good positions you were
getting out of the opening in blitz
against
prep for icarus much but my prep
doesn't work really well
and he he also played the position that
i prepared better than
myself today and uh
he just outplayed me tactically
i i guess it was
[Music]
the main things why i lost so many
permission position his concentration
was
on the another level so today i'm was
not able to
to play uh as good as i can but
also he shows some something
that's i'm not expected right
yeah and i mean hikaru really i mean it
was such a dominant performance by you
you're going to move on to face wesley
so somebody who you've played many times
in speeches championships past and
recently in the skilling open
what is your mindset like going into
that semi-final matchup
um i mean i think it's more the same
just just play good solid chess um but
certainly you know it's it's payback
time so
um i'm gonna i'm gonna be out for for
blood i will i will uh say that much
um yeah but i think i think mainly it's
just uh just just playing well
in general being solid and i thought
today i was very solid
um especially the five plus one three
plus one started to get a little bit
messy at times and
i mean my concentration was really
drifting uh because i mean after winning
that five percent it just it felt like
the match match wasn't really uh
competitive um but yeah mainly against
wesley just playing more good chess and
um
and just uh just just do more of what i
did today
and obviously wearing that hoodie
because clearly clearly that looks good
on you feels good right
yeah but i mean like that wasn't
intentional i was gonna wear something
else but then i
then i uh i had to i had to move a lot
of stuff over to my apartment this
morning so i i like it
it was crazy i just threw something on
but i'll wear it again yeah
i mean jokes aside it looks to be uh
look looks good for you um
yeah well again we don't want to keep
you guys too long we know it's late for
you vladimir and again
uh you had you had an incredible year uh
one of the most consistent dominant
players on chess.com and in the speeches
grand prix so
um we know today didn't go the way you
wanted but congratulations on a great
year
and uh and thank you so much for for the
interview here
thank you daniel uh thank you uh
for a good match and for
all the viewers who
probably enjoyed this match i hope so
thank you bye